A Miracle of Modern Missions:
cue-2
The Story of Matula, a Congo Convert
cue-3
God our Father, full of kindness,
cue-4
look upon our country,
cue-5
every land which sin has cursed and where
deep darkness still remains.
cue-6
God our Father,
cue-7
full of kindness,
cue-8
look upon our country.
cue-9
By John Bell,
cue-10
Baptist Missionary.
cue-11
Originally published in 1900, revised for
easier readability in 2025,
cue-12
but not abridged.
cue-13
Audiobook produced by scrollreader.com.
cue-14
Introductory note by J.B. Wathen,
Secretary of the Baptist Missionary
cue-15
Society.
cue-16
Not long before he died, Alfred Saker, one
of Africa's earliest missionaries, wrote
cue-17
that nothing brings a missionary more joy
or strength than seeing God's grace
cue-18
at work in the lives of the people he
serves.
cue-19
He called these miracles of missions,
cue-20
old ways passing away and everything
becoming new, and found in them proof that
cue-21
God's promise never fails.
cue-22
My word will not return to me empty, but
will accomplish what I desire and achieve
cue-23
the purpose for which I sent it.
cue-24
The story of Matula, told here by Mr. Bell
from Wathen Station on the Lower Congo
cue-25
River, is another remarkable example of
the gospel's power to transform even
cue-26
the most broken and uneducated lives.
cue-27
Few accounts in modern missions are as
moving and inspiring as the work among the
cue-28
Congo's formerly cannibal tribes over the
past 24 years.
cue-29
Their dramatic turn to faith makes a
strong case for sending the lamp of life
cue-30
into every dark corner of Central Africa.
cue-31
Matula stayed true to his savior even
under the harshest persecution.
cue-32
He trusted God completely when he faced
certain death at the hands of powerful
cue-33
enemies, never doubting that his father in
heaven was in control. He showed no fear,
cue-34
despite the spite and treachery of those
who hunted him. We can thank
cue-35
God that his grace shone so clearly in
Matula's life.
cue-36
Today, his bold witness has changed his
hometown of Mongo.
cue-37
A prayer house now stands there. Chief
Lunenga has been baptized, and 60 to
cue-38
70 children attend school, taught by a
local Christian teacher.
cue-39
Few mission fields have seen local
believers lead such wide outreach as the
cue-40
Congo mission.
cue-41
From the start, every church member has
taken on a personal share of service.
cue-42
At Wathen Station, the native church
supports 15 local evangelists.
cue-43
44 outstations are visited by native
workers. Schools have
cue-44
1,507 day students and 807 Sunday
students,
cue-45
and 15 people form the Wathen Temperance
Society.
cue-46
All costs for this evangelistic and
educational work are covered by the native
cue-47
Christians themselves.
cue-48
Mr. Bell's sympathetic portrait of Matula
will surely fuel more missionary passion.
cue-49
It may inspire many young men to dedicate
their lives to bringing Africa to
cue-50
Christ.
cue-51
To most readers, it may seem I've become
overly enthusiastic about the life of a
cue-52
simple Congolese man.
cue-53
Yet we should value truth, sincerity, and
honesty wherever they appear,
cue-54
remembering that God made all nations from
one family,
cue-55
and we are all his children.
cue-56
Africans have rightly been judged harshly
for habits of submission, cunning, and
cue-57
cruelty.
cue-58
But when in such a setting, we find an
African gentleman despised by his peers
cue-59
for his honesty, sincerity, and kindness,
and know he represents many more,
cue-60
we owe it to him to give thanks to God
and be encouraged. The tale of Matula's
cue-61
remarkable escape was told across England,
Ireland, and America by the Reverend
cue-62
R.H.C. Graham of San Salvador during his
furloughs in 1898 and
cue-63
1899.
cue-64
Many urged him to publish it as a
pamphlet. He hoped it would fit into Mr.
cue-65
Bentley's then-in-progress Pioneering on
the Congo, but Bentley ultimately could
cue-66
not make room for it.
cue-67
I, too, had intended to write Matula's
story after his return to Ngombe.
cue-68
Soon afterward, I went home on furlough,
and other duties filled my time until I
cue-69
nearly forgot.
cue-70
In 1901, I met Matula traveling to the
station.
cue-71
He looked frail.
cue-72
We feared sleep sickness,
cue-73
and we thought he might not live long,
cue-74
taking his story with him.
cue-75
I arranged to meet him and his wife the
next morning and over the following days,
cue-76
and from their accounts, I gathered the
key facts of his life.
cue-77
When I told Mr. Graham about my plan, he
kindly urged me to go ahead and succeed,
cue-78
and he sent the full report of Matula's
trial, which he witnessed himself.
cue-79
I am deeply grateful to him.
cue-80
I'm sure everyone who heard parts of
Matula's story from Mr. Graham or me
cue-81
during deputation will welcome this brief
yet complete account of his life.
cue-82
This little book is dedicated to all who
have shared, even in the smallest way,
cue-83
in bringing the gospel to the dark land of
the Congo.
cue-84
Chapter 1. Without Hope
cue-85
Before 1871, no one really knew what lay
deep inside the Congo.
cue-86
People thought it could never be explored
because the forests, rivers, and swamps
cue-87
were so hard to cross.
cue-88
Many tried and failed, and for years the
heart of Africa remained a blank spot on
cue-89
the map.
cue-90
Then Henry Stanley made his daring
journey. He started at Zanzibar on the
cue-91
east coast, traveled across the continent,
and finally reached the mouth of the
cue-92
Congo River on the west coast.
cue-93
His trip let the world see the land's
rivers, forests, and mountains, and meet
cue-94
some of the people who lived there. Yet
most of their story stayed hidden,
cue-95
and for the most part, still is.
cue-96
Still, we can notice some general things
about the Congo peoples. All their
cue-97
dialects share a simple, clear structure,
and they nearly use the same word for
cue-98
God.Long ago, their ancestors built huts,
made spears, forged
cue-99
hoes, and farmed the land with skill and
care.
cue-100
Over time, however, they stopped inventing
new tools or ideas. They copied old ways
cue-101
without creating anything new.
cue-102
Action and thought feed each other.
cue-103
But when people turn away from what is
good and give in to their lowest desires,
cue-104
their minds grow dull.
cue-105
They find it hard even to imagine pure
thoughts, let alone live by them.
cue-106
As the Bible says, when people are given
over to vile passions, they ignore God's
cue-107
creation and focus only on themselves.
cue-108
We don't know exactly when or how the
Congo peoples lost the light they once
cue-109
had, but the darkness closed in because
they refused to acknowledge God.
cue-110
In their present state, these people know
God's name but are so bound by
cue-111
superstition that anyone who speaks of him
is called a sorcerer. They refuse to
cue-112
listen about God, and mentioning him marks
you as a witch.
cue-113
Expecting widespread progress among them
is useless.
cue-114
Yet occasionally in such a setting, you
meet someone utterly different from those
cue-115
around him. He lives in that world but
rises above it.
cue-116
For him, we must accept a simple truth.
cue-117
Even in the darkest places and among the
most degraded, God always leaves a
cue-118
witness.
cue-119
That person often doesn't understand his
own conflict. He joins the crowd watching
cue-120
horrors that his whole being rejects while
others cheer murder.
cue-121
At times, he may take part in their wild
rites, but he is never happy and hides his
cue-122
feelings, knowing they will be
misunderstood.
cue-123
The people call him a witch and feel
uneasy around him, though they can't say
cue-124
why.
cue-125
He has no clear light to guide him and
doesn't know where to find it. Many such
cue-126
souls have lived and died in the Congo
through the ages. Their quiet resistance
cue-127
held back total evil, but only just.
cue-128
Matula was one of these until the gospel
came. Without the work of Christian
cue-129
missionaries, he would have lived and
died, hated by his peers and misunderstood
cue-130
by his friends, simply because his
gentle, humble nature clashed with
cue-131
everything around him.
cue-132
Much of this may seem exaggerated or hard
to believe, but it helps to remember how
cue-133
simple and how trusting the average Congo
native can be. He
cue-134
dreams often and believes his dreams are
real.
cue-135
He echoes Tennyson's line,
cue-136
Dreams are true while they last, and adds,
And we must take revenge for our dreams.
cue-137
I wouldn't be surprised if many people in
the Congo have been murdered because
cue-138
someone, convinced by a dream, believed
their enemy had done them harm
cue-139
there. To them, a dream is as real as any
waking event.
cue-140
They live surrounded by powerful
superstitions. A rustling leaf might be a
cue-141
spirit moving nearby, and anything unusual
is blamed on witchcraft.
cue-142
Anyone who shines at a craft or excels in
trade is suspected of having a spirit's
cue-143
help and might be killed to stop future
harm.
cue-144
They believe deeply in fate and feel
powerless to avoid disaster.
cue-145
A person accused of witchcraft usually
accepts the challenge to prove their
cue-146
innocence, certain they will pass the
test.
cue-147
If they fail, the community feels
justified in punishing them.
cue-148
They think a stranger can't bewitch them,
so when illness or death strikes, they
cue-149
search only among the victim's own people
for a witch.
cue-150
Every sickness, every death is blamed on
sorcery. In hunting or
cue-151
fighting, they believe no one can be
harmed or no animal taken unless they
cue-152
first honor their fetish.
cue-153
Even in war, if a warrior falls, they say
he was hit by the enemy's fetish but
cue-154
actually killed by a witch among his own
side. In almost every part of life,
cue-155
people feel controlled either by fetishism
or by witchcraft, sometimes both at
cue-156
once.
cue-157
For instance, if a disease won't yield to
a fetish's power, they turn to witchcraft,
cue-158
or in war they may use both methods
together.
cue-159
Families are also defined very broadly.
cue-160
All members of a clan, or even everyone
from the same town, call each other
cue-161
brothers and sisters.
cue-162
A mother's brothers and sisters are all
called mothers, and a father's brothers
cue-163
and sisters are all fathers.
cue-164
With so many mothers and fathers, it can
be nearly impossible to tell who someone's
cue-165
real parents are,
cue-166
and so children end up with many mothers
and many fathers. This book isn't meant to
cue-167
explain all the customs and beliefs of
the Congolese people.
cue-168
I mention them only when they help tell
Matula's story.
cue-169
My goal is simply to share the life of one
of our kindest and most devoted native
cue-170
Christians.
cue-171
I hope readers will trust its truth and
thank God, who wonderfully guided and
cue-172
protected Matula in his darkest times.
cue-173
Chapter 2.
cue-174
Birth of Matula.
cue-175
For ages, the Congo lay in darkness,
cue-176
so dark that no one knew when it began.
cue-177
After a long pitch-black stretch, people
on the coast shouted, The dawn is here!
cue-178
The dawn is here!
cue-179
They meant the first missionaries from
Rome had arrived to share Christianity.
cue-180
But their visit was like a single flash of
lightning in a stormy sky,
cue-181
brief and leaving no real light.
cue-182
That true dawn would not come for nearly
two hundred more years.
cue-183
By then, the people had fallen into the
lowest level of cruelty and chaos one can
cue-184
imagine. There was no law or order. The
strong enslaved the weak,
cue-185
even selling their former masters.
cue-186
Bands of raiders captured anyone traveling
alone and sold them as slaves. Would-be
cue-187
rulers filled their towns with stolen
people. No one could seek help or
cue-188
justice. Everyone lived in fear. Yet even
in that disorder, a few
cue-189
crafts survived.
cue-190
Blacksmiths still worked iron, and potters
shaped clay into pots.
cue-191
When Europeans settled on the coast
hundreds of years earlier, they brought
cue-192
new tools and goods.Those items reached
the interior by trading hands.
cue-193
The Congolese people, skilled at copying,
made rough versions of what they saw:
cue-194
simple clothes, basic wooden furniture,
doing their best to carry on these
cue-195
trades despite the darkness around them.
cue-196
They couldn't make guns themselves, so
they bought them at very high prices. The
cue-197
farther inland you went, the fewer you
saw.
cue-198
Many blacksmiths did a good business
making bullets and slugs for hunting and
cue-199
war.
cue-200
People knew how to work iron well, even
though they didn't mine it
cue-201
deeply. When one spot's surface ore ran
out, they simply moved on to a
cue-202
richer one. About twenty years before
Comber and Hartland
cue-203
arrived at Mbanza Makuta in 1880, there
was a town nearby called Mongo.
cue-204
It was founded by four brothers, Nimu and
his siblings, who were skilled smiths.
cue-205
They were prosperous and owned many
slaves.
cue-206
Supplying bullets and slugs across the
countryside made them wealthy, but as they
cue-207
had to go farther for ore, they decided
to settle on a prime site and named it
cue-208
Mongo.
cue-209
Nimu, the eldest, became chief, and a
harsh one at that. He feared any nephew
cue-210
might grow up to challenge him.
cue-211
Whenever one of his brothers had a baby,
he demanded to know its sex.
cue-212
If it was a boy, he killed the child with
a blow to the head.
cue-213
Girls, however, increased his wealth.
Their future husbands paid a high bride
cue-214
price, often right after birth. His
brothers could not stand his cruelty
cue-215
forever.
cue-216
They each built their own towns.
cue-217
One brother, Mpanzu, founded Nsamba just a
short distance away.
cue-218
But Nimu kept tormenting them,
cue-219
so they plotted to remove him.
cue-220
On a market day, they accused him of
witchcraft and forced him to drink poison.
cue-221
As he weakened, they clubbed him to death
and looted all his possessions. About the
cue-222
time Nimu was killed, another blacksmith
named Nku settled a little south of Mongo.
cue-223
He brought his favorite young wife,
Mundele, a name borrowed from the word for
cue-224
white man, since cloth first came from
Europeans, along with their slaves
cue-225
and belongings.
cue-226
They had come from a district over sixty
miles to the southeast.
cue-227
Nku was well known for the anklets,
bracelets, and necklets he forged, and he
cue-228
often traveled far to sell them. He found
a great market in the Makuta area, where
cue-229
he also smelted iron ore. There he struck
up a strong friendship with
cue-230
Mpanzu of Nsamba.
cue-231
On returning from one profitable trip, Nku
discovered his household nearly starving.
cue-232
So he decided to move closer to Mpanzu,
hoping for better security and trade.
cue-233
His wife and the other women were uneasy.
If anything happened to Nku among
cue-234
strangers, they feared being sold as
slaves.
cue-235
But the promise of a safer, more
prosperous life won them over.
cue-236
They built their new home about an hour or
two south of Mongo, not far from Nsamba.
cue-237
Mpanzu was delighted to have his friend so
close. To the north ruled Lunyanga,
cue-238
the proud and cruel chief of Nkondo. He
was known to execute anyone who offended
cue-239
him, even slightly.
cue-240
As Nku's fame and skill spread, Lunyanga
grew jealous and looked for a reason to
cue-241
strike.
cue-242
His harsh rule soon drew the ire of
neighboring chiefs, who fined him slaves
cue-243
and a large sum of shell money for
mistreating his people.
cue-244
Unwilling to pay, Lunyanga devised a
darker plan. He would kill Nku and
cue-245
seize his wealth to cover the fine.
cue-246
He whispered his scheme to his own slaves,
promising them rich rewards,
cue-247
and they eagerly agreed, for they had
joined him on such raids before. They
cue-248
planned to strike that very night so word
wouldn't spread. As soon as darkness
cue-249
fell, Lunyanga's men,
cue-250
guns loaded, ammunition ready, slipped
past Mongo and Nsamba and crept
cue-251
into Kinzembo, where Nku's village lay in
deep sleep. They surrounded the chief's
cue-252
compound, posted lookouts by every exit,
and then, at a signal, opened fire
cue-253
into the huts.
cue-254
The men who rushed out were shot. The
women and girls were seized as captives.
cue-255
In barely an hour, they looted everything
of value and marched their prisoners back
cue-256
to Nkondo, arriving before dawn.
cue-257
By morning, the massacre was known
everywhere, yet no one dared seek justice.
cue-258
Many even celebrated.
cue-259
"This land is ours,"
cue-260
they proclaimed, and Lunyanga's pride and
power grew.
cue-261
Those who had fined him earlier lost the
courage to demand their payment.
cue-262
Mpanzu grieved for Nku but had no means to
punish Lunyanga.
cue-263
To protect Nku's beloved young wife,
Mundele, from slavery at strange hands,
cue-264
he bought her freedom and married her
himself.
cue-265
He treated her with deep affection and
stored all his precious goods in her home,
cue-266
a high mark of his esteem. As a wealthy
trader wanting an heir of his own blood,
cue-267
Mpanzu prized Mundele above his other
wives, since children born to free women
cue-268
belonged to their mother's family. Only a
son by Mundele would carry on Mpanzu's
cue-269
name and inheritance. Mundele and Mpanzu
soon had a child, but it died
cue-270
very young.
cue-271
They were heartbroken. When another baby
came, it also died.
cue-272
Mpanzu mourned deeply, but Mundele
suffered even more.
cue-273
She accused him of casting spells on their
children. She could not forget that she
cue-274
had once been free and respected among
women.
cue-275
Now she was a slave, her first husband
dead,
cue-276
her babies gone. The grief nearly drove
her mad.
cue-277
One day her friends noticed she was
missing.
cue-278
After searching, they found her in the
woods, lying in a small pool of blood.
cue-279
She was almost unconscious.
cue-280
They carried her home, and after several
days she recovered.
cue-281
In her despair, she had cut her own throat
to end her life.
cue-282
Poor Mundele knew nothing of why people
suffer or where comfort comes from.
cue-283
She only knew God's name, and she called
on it again and again, crying,
cue-284
"Nzambi ovanga-kansi kaze ye vanga ko."
cue-285
God creates,
cue-286
but he does not know how to create.Her
heart was dark with pain, and she
cue-287
did not realize that God hears and answers
even the most anguished cries.
cue-288
Yet in truth, her desperate prayer looked
for a dawn after that long night of
cue-289
sorrow.
cue-290
And God did answer. Her husband's family
and even she herself thought her
cue-291
outburst was pagan superstition, but
before long she gave birth to a daughter
cue-292
who lived.
cue-293
Soon after came a son, whom they named
Matula.
cue-294
Brighter days had arrived. In time she
bore seven healthy children, an almost
cue-295
unheard-of blessing in the Congo. She
would live to see the light of a new day
cue-296
for her land, and four or five of her
children would grow up to be earnest,
cue-297
faithful Christians.
cue-298
Chapter 3. Childhood of Matula
cue-299
Childhood in the Congo can seem full of
freedom, but it is often harsh and lonely.
cue-300
From dawn to dusk, children roam outdoors,
chasing insects or whatever catches their
cue-301
eye, with nobody to call them home or
tell them to go to bed.
cue-302
Even before they can crawl, a Congo baby
is tied to its mother's back each morning
cue-303
and carried into the fields.
cue-304
The infant's first view is the load
balanced on her head, sometimes baskets of
cue-305
vegetables, a bundle of firewood, or a
heavy pot of water. As the child
cue-306
grows, it learns to carry awkward loads on
its own head, since no one in the
cue-307
Congo would carry on their arm what they
can hold on their head.
cue-308
Once in the garden, the little one is set
down under a bush while the mother hoes
cue-309
the earth.
cue-310
If the baby cries, she stops to nurse it.
Then either the child falls asleep or she
cue-311
straps it back onto her back, where it
finds a cradle of safety. Soon it begins
cue-312
to crawl, exploring and sampling whatever
it can reach, fruits,
cue-313
leaves, insects, learning by trial which
things are safe to eat.
cue-314
The mother only intervenes when the child
touches a poisonous plant.
cue-315
As they grow, children chase caterpillars,
frogs, and rats, and in doing so they
cue-316
learn for themselves which creatures make
good food. They also pick up practical
cue-317
knowledge of plants, which ones feed them,
which heal, and which harm.
cue-318
Girls stay with their mothers, learning to
weed, hoe, sow, plant, and cook
cue-319
all the way into young womanhood.
cue-320
Boys spend only the first four or five
years by their mother's side.
cue-321
After that, they must look after
themselves.
cue-322
When a boy is old enough, he joins the
older boys in the woods all day. No
cue-323
school, no punishments, just freedom
unless they start a fight.
cue-324
Then the village holds a palaver to sort
out who was wrong.
cue-325
As they wander, they watch ants,
squirrels, monkeys, and track antelope
cue-326
through the undergrowth. Their favorite
pastime is rat hunting, and when they
cue-327
bring home a good catch, their mother has
no trouble serving meat with their cassava
cue-328
pudding. When a boy reaches about eight
years old, he may build a small hut for
cue-329
himself or go live with some older boys.
cue-330
By that age, he feels too grown up to stay
close to his mother,
cue-331
except perhaps when he's hungry.
cue-332
Around this time, he begins wearing a
cloth, and the men of the village may
cue-333
start to notice him.
cue-334
They might take him on trading trips and
use him for heavy work, though they give
cue-335
him a small payment.
cue-336
Some of my younger readers might think,
what a fun life those Congo boys must
cue-337
have. No one to call them, no one to
bother them, no one to punish them.
cue-338
Wouldn't it be great to live like that for
a while?
cue-339
Yes, perhaps it would,
cue-340
for a short time.
cue-341
But when I felt very lonely, I would want
someone to keep me in check.
cue-342
When I was tired and weary of always
having my own way, I would want someone to
cue-343
care enough to bother with me.
cue-344
And when I did something I knew was very
wrong,
cue-345
I would want someone to correct me,
because that would bring peace to my
cue-346
conscience.
cue-347
It's sad how quickly these children grow
tired of wandering.
cue-348
It gives them no purpose.
cue-349
Soon they are left standing around the
village, looking dull and alone, with no
cue-350
one to guide them and nothing to interest
them. When they fall sick, there is no one
cue-351
to help,
cue-352
because,
cue-353
poor little ones, no one knows how to care
for the sick or give proper treatment.
cue-354
If a child becomes ill, a local healer
might be called.
cue-355
He will rub his hand over the child's body
and say some words.
cue-356
But when the illness becomes serious,
there is no one to cool the hot forehead,
cue-357
no one to moisten dry lips, no one to sing
a gentle song to comfort the child.
cue-358
Drums may be beaten, and traditional
dances may begin, but these
cue-359
only disturb the suffering child.
cue-360
As the fever rises, the child's covering
may be taken off, and the dancers become
cue-361
louder, dancing, shouting, and calling
out,
cue-362
until the little one may pass away, killed
by exposure and cold.
cue-363
Not from cruelty, but from a deep, dark
ignorance.
cue-364
Those who grow up in the Congo really live
by survival of the fittest.
cue-365
It was in that setting that Matula was
born and raised.
cue-366
His childhood was much like what I have
already described for any boy.
cue-367
When he was about eight, his father gave
him a small drum. Many days he would play
cue-368
it for himself, calling the other boys and
girls to dance just like the grown-ups.
cue-369
They would copy the funeral, wedding, and
fetish dances, which are all quite
cue-370
similar, and only a keen ear can tell them
apart.
cue-371
They played house and pretended to cook
and clean, but not for long.
cue-372
One day was especially exciting.
cue-373
After an argument with the townspeople,
Matula's father decided to move the whole
cue-374
village about a quarter of a mile away.
cue-375
Matula didn't mind the quarrel. He loved
the excitement of moving,
cue-376
what we call flitting.
cue-377
Moving a village from one place to another
is common there. People move for many
cue-378
reasons, jealousy, sickness, lack of food,
or bad neighbors.
cue-379
Those planning to move help each other.
cue-380
First they choose and mark the new site.
Then they take apart their old houses,
cue-381
lifting off roofs, removing walls, and
carrying each piece to the new
cue-382
spot.Strong men carry the uprights and
ridgepoles, and then the roofs.
cue-383
In one day, they can tear down and rebuild
several houses. Matula enjoyed helping
cue-384
move his father's houses for his wives
and slaves.
cue-385
The quarrel that caused the move didn't
last long, and he was happy to return to
cue-386
the old site.
cue-387
He was a cheerful boy those days,
especially when his father took him to
cue-388
market. He knew they would not come home
empty-handed. But some days he had to wait
cue-389
for hours on the road while his father
drank palm wine with friends.
cue-390
Sometimes the children were called to
drink too, and so they learned to be
cue-391
drunkards from an early age. As a boy, his
mother never let him go to the town
cue-392
dance, a dance beyond words.
cue-393
He watched his parents dress for it,
wearing their finest clothes and jewelry.
cue-394
His father draped a leopard skin over
himself, hung a knife at his waist, and
cue-395
styled his hair in ridges or shaved
patterns with patches of red ochre on his
cue-396
face.
cue-397
His mother wore bright anklets, a necklace
of beads or shells, touches of red on her
cue-398
cheeks, and elaborate haircuts. They
usually set off late at night, locking
cue-399
the little ones inside the house. The
children fell asleep to the drum's steady
cue-400
thump and the dancers' constant jingle.
cue-401
It was a carefree, happy, yet touching
childhood.
cue-402
Matula slept peacefully, unaware of the
future trials before him.
cue-403
Oh, childhood, how many would give
anything to return to your innocence, your
cue-404
playful pranks?
cue-405
Yet later, Matula discovered another
childhood,
cue-406
one known only to those who live under the
Gospel. That alone makes coming to the
cue-407
Congo worthwhile, to bring this true
childhood even to those who hear the wild
cue-408
cries of slaves sold or beaten,
cue-409
or the silent groans of their murdered
victims.
cue-410
Without Christ, this land remains dark and
hopeless, with no restored childhood
cue-411
and no forgiveness for the guilty.
cue-412
Chapter Four: Murder of His Father.
cue-413
One day, Mpanzu sent his ten-year-old son
to the market with him. Matula was
cue-414
overjoyed, and he never forgot that trip,
for it was the last time they went
cue-415
together.
cue-416
In the market, people talked about the
many deaths around them and how few
cue-417
children were being born. Everyone feared
their people would disappear unless they
cue-418
acted. They talked of two plans: to form a
secret society called
cue-419
Ndenbo, described in Mr. Bentley's
Pioneering on the Congo,
cue-420
or to find the witch they blamed for the
deaths.
cue-421
After much debate, they chose the secret
society, hoping it would protect the young
cue-422
if the elders died.
cue-423
Matula did not hear when the Ndenbo
meeting would be,
cue-424
so he and his father walked home,
cue-425
carefree.
cue-426
His father carried half a sheep to share
at home.
cue-427
All the children sat on the ground like
puppies, watching him cut the meat.
cue-428
There were so many that it was hard to
give everyone a fair share.
cue-429
Matula wanted a big bone, but it went to
his older half-brother. He burst into
cue-430
tears, refused the smaller piece, and was
sent to bed by his father.
cue-431
He did not remain upset for long.
cue-432
Before bedtime, he heard the drum and the
witch doctor's chant. He crept
cue-433
outside and lay on the ground as if dead.
cue-434
Others did the same, covering themselves
with cloth.
cue-435
There was singing and gunfire, and then
all who died were carried to a camp in the
cue-436
woods just outside town.
cue-437
Matula counted about one hundred boys and
girls there, most from nearby
cue-438
villages. He stayed in that camp for
nearly ten months, taking part in their
cue-439
empty, sensual rituals.
cue-440
The children chose him as their leader and
gave him a new name, Masamba.
cue-441
No one dared come near the camp. To the
townspeople, they were truly dead.
cue-442
Matula heard nothing of the world outside
until his return,
cue-443
and then he learned the terrible news that
his father had been murdered.
cue-444
After they formed the Ndenbo, everyone
told themselves that sickness and death
cue-445
would leave them.
cue-446
For a few weeks, it seemed to work.
cue-447
But when the cold, dry season arrived,
like a harsh winter, it found the weak and
cue-448
old, and every year it claimed its share
of graves. They asked, "How can
cue-449
we stop this terrible death? Who is the
witch?"
cue-450
Their suspicions fell on one man,
cue-451
Mpanzu. If only he had been happy with one
wife and a small trading business,
cue-452
things might have been different.
cue-453
But his ambition and greed did him in, as
they have done to many, even in
cue-454
Christian lands. He had over a dozen wives
and thirty or forty children.
cue-455
He was a famous, wealthy trader.
cue-456
So why did he have so many children when
others had none or were dying?
cue-457
Why was he rich while his relatives were
poor?
cue-458
To them, there was only one answer:
cue-459
witchcraft.
cue-460
They called a big meeting with the witch
doctor,
cue-461
but they did not invite Mpanzu. In the
middle of the doctor's fierce, swirling
cue-462
dance, he shouted Mpanzu's name.
cue-463
"It's Mpanzu." Everyone agreed. They
planned that early the next morning, some
cue-464
friends would lure the townspeople away
with a controlled bushfire while Mpanzu
cue-465
would stay behind to drink palm wine with
visiting chiefs. At dawn, the hunters
cue-466
set off, excited, chasing rats, wild cats,
and antelopes fleeing the
cue-467
flames.
cue-468
Mpanzu felt honored by the chiefs'
arrival. They came in solemn, stately
cue-469
procession as if they were lords of
creation.
cue-470
Mats were laid for them to sit on, and
they exchanged formal greetings.
cue-471
Then the calabash of palm wine was brought
out, hands clapped, and the drink passed
cue-472
around in proper order.
cue-473
The calabash went around again.
cue-474
When Mpanzu lifted it to his lips, his
last drink, the killer standing behind him
cue-475
quietly slipped a noose over his head.
cue-476
They carried him away with no wife or
child nearby to weep or plead.
cue-477
Their plan was made in secret, and they
took him to an even more hidden spot.There
cue-478
they did their cruel deed, thinking they
were doing right by removing a witch.
cue-479
They beat him brutally, then hung him from
a tree and left his body to rot.
cue-480
Truly, the darkest places on earth hide
the worst cruelty.
cue-481
Oh Earth, when will you give up the blood
of your slaughtered sons? When will the
cue-482
innocent be avenged?
cue-483
All across the Congo, almost every hour,
the cry of some murdered victim
cue-484
rose up, asking for justice.
cue-485
It was a cry in the night, but God, who
never sleeps, heard it, and thank God He
cue-486
answered.
cue-487
Today, in part, that answer has come.
Peace declared, sin forgiven for all who
cue-488
accept it, even those whose hands are
stained with blood. Many in the Congo have
cue-489
atoned for their terrible sins. Through
Christ, they stand cleansed and
cue-490
redeemed.
cue-491
Poor Matula felt his father's murder more
deeply than any other sorrow he had known.
cue-492
His father had been proud of him. Matula
was meant to be his heir.
cue-493
Now he returned to find no money left, his
mother sold as a slave to another man,
cue-494
and all his father's slaves and herds
scattered by sale.
cue-495
Now this eleven-year-old boy must earn his
living by trading, both to avoid being
cue-496
sold himself and to help free his mother
from slavery.
cue-497
Chapter Five: First News of the White Man
cue-498
Matula was no longer a child. He had to go
out into the world to help his mother win
cue-499
her freedom and to care for his five
younger brothers and sisters.
cue-500
About a year had passed since the last
chapter, and now Matula was on his way to
cue-501
market with his mother.
cue-502
He had become a young trader and visited
all the nearby markets. There was a
cue-503
rotating daily market held in four
different towns, returning to the first
cue-504
spot every fourth day.
cue-505
This system meant each town had frequent
markets, and in many areas people could
cue-506
reach a market every day with little
trouble.
cue-507
On this particular morning, Matula and his
mother arrived early at the open market
cue-508
square.
cue-509
Let us join them and watch the traders
coming in from every direction. Women
cue-510
carried baskets heavy with kwanga,
plantains, palm nuts, ground nuts, nezalu,
cue-511
and pineapples, either balanced on their
heads or slung over their shoulders. Men
cue-512
appeared too, one with cloth draped over
his shoulders, another showing off
cue-513
polished anklets, one dragging a goat by
its legs, another carrying two chickens
cue-514
under his arm, and yet another with a
small bag of salt.
cue-515
The sellers squatted on the ground and
arranged their goods in front of them.
cue-516
Buyers wove among the stalls, haggling
over small amounts of goods, yet they
cue-517
wasted just as much time, breath, and
temper here as they would over large sums
cue-518
back home.
cue-519
Nearby, a group of palm wine drinkers held
court, and bundles of firewood lay in
cue-520
waiting.
cue-521
"What's happening, Matula?"
cue-522
his mother asked.
cue-523
"Wait and see,"
cue-524
he whispered.
cue-525
Soon a boy knelt to light the firewood.
cue-526
The man with the goat began beating it,
cue-527
not hard enough to kill at first, but with
steady strokes that drove the frightened
cue-528
animal to exhaustion.
cue-529
Finally, the goat collapsed, still alive.
They dragged it onto the blazing fire. It
cue-530
was too cruel to watch, better to move on
before we hear its desperate bleating.
cue-531
This brutal practice still goes on today
and will not end until a law forbids
cue-532
it.
cue-533
Our own influence, wherever it reaches,
stands firmly against such needless
cue-534
cruelty.
cue-535
Leaving that horrifying scene behind, we
noticed a crowd staring in another
cue-536
direction.
cue-537
Far off, a long line of men was marching
toward the market from Mbanza Makuta,
cue-538
each carrying a gun.
cue-539
"Isn't that against the law?"
cue-540
some asked. "Yes,"
cue-541
one replied, "but there's more to it.
cue-542
I've heard there was a war at Makuta. A
white man came there months ago, then
cue-543
tried to return.
cue-544
Bwaka Matu wouldn't let him pass.
cue-545
He drove him out and shot him."
cue-546
"Is he dead?" another asked.
cue-547
"I don't know," came the answer. "I hope
so."
cue-548
"Was he one of the coastal traders?"
cue-549
"No. They say he was a mundil,
cue-550
a man of God,
cue-551
a missionary."
cue-552
Matula listened closely to these rumors.
cue-553
Soon he heard the singer leading a
procession nearby and strained to catch
cue-554
every word of the song that boasted how
the white man had been driven off and
cue-555
shot by their mighty chief.
cue-556
At last, the singer appeared, his forehead
and nose streaked with red.
cue-557
Behind him came the chief, draped in a
long cloth and wearing a leopard-skin cap,
cue-558
carrying a spear.
cue-559
In single file, about a hundred warriors
followed, each with a gun or
cue-560
spear. The singer began again.
cue-561
"Great is our chief. Who can stand against
him?"
cue-562
The chief paced before the crowd, showing
himself off,
cue-563
kusonga, as Matula called it.
cue-564
He challenged anyone who sided with the
white man and swore that no nunkwa malu
cue-565
mole, trouser wearer, would ever enter his
land again.
cue-566
Only he was chief.
cue-567
The people abandoned their trading, joined
the song and dance, and declared, "Never
cue-568
again shall a white man appear in our
country."
cue-569
Some of the timid feared the white man
might return in force for revenge.
cue-570
In truth, the chief had only wounded the
white man,
cue-571
not killed him.
cue-572
That man was Tom Comber, who with Hartland
had tried to build a road to Stanley
cue-573
Pool.
cue-574
Because of Bwaka Matu's stubbornness, the
road effort was abandoned for a time, and
cue-575
Makuta stood alone for several years.
cue-576
About seven or eight years later, Mr.
Bentley visited the town.
cue-577
He has come twice a year on average ever
since, and his work has brought wonderful
cue-578
results. Revenge was taken, but not by
sword.
cue-579
Today, Makuta has one of the most thriving
sections of our native church.
cue-580
Mr. Bentley describes this transformation
in his book.In August
cue-581
1897, Nkonzi, nephew of Bwaka Matu, who
had ordered Komba shot,
cue-582
was baptized.
cue-583
A month or two later, he felt the need to
make amends for his family's great sin.
cue-584
He wanted to send a gift to Komba's
father, but being far away, he could only
cue-585
manage something small.
cue-586
He wrote a letter expressing deep sorrow
for the wrong done to his son, who had
cue-587
brought such good news from God.
cue-588
He explained that his uncle Bwaka had
acted in ignorance and begged Komba's
cue-589
father to forgive him and be his friend.
cue-590
Nkonzi had come to know and trust Jesus
and was truly thankful that the gospel
cue-591
had reached his people. This was God's
own vengeance, turning many of that
cue-592
proud, wicked chief's relatives to faith.
Nkonzi himself, however, did not
cue-593
live long after his misdeed.
cue-594
But that is a brief aside. Returning to
Matula, this was the first time he had
cue-595
ever heard of white men, so he listened
eagerly to every rumor.
cue-596
He heard them called possessors of two
legs, as if other men had none.
cue-597
The white men on the coast were traders,
but these two who came to Makuta were
cue-598
different.
cue-599
They gave away fine cloth and spoke of
Nzambi, our God,
cue-600
and strange things like
cue-601
love.
cue-602
These Mundul, white men, were entirely
odd. They had no guns
cue-603
and hadn't brought many carriers to force
a road.
cue-604
No one knew who they really were or what
they wanted. Some believed their home lay
cue-605
at the bottom of the sea. Perhaps they
were spirits of sold slaves come back to
cue-606
haunt them.
cue-607
In any case, they were said to be eaters
of men, carrying off as many as they could
cue-608
to work in their strange land.
cue-609
The only safe course was never to let them
return, and wherever their name was
cue-610
heard, to avoid them as Ndoki,
cue-611
witches.
cue-612
All of this terrified young Matula.
cue-613
As he walked home from market that day
with his mother, he prayed he would never
cue-614
meet a white man in his life.
cue-615
Though he tried not to think of them by
day, he dreamed of them at night.
cue-616
Sometimes in one form, sometimes another.
cue-617
Always chasing him, never letting him
escape.
cue-618
Yet he was destined to have much to do
with these very white men.
cue-619
And, as dreams often turn out opposite to
reality, in later years Matula grew
cue-620
to love white men dearly and was glad to
turn to them for help and protection.
cue-621
Chapter 6. The White Man
cue-622
Matula was determined to avoid contact
with white men as much as he
cue-623
could. Over the next few years, he made
good progress as a trader.
cue-624
Even though he was still young, people saw
him as very sharp, and he made money
cue-625
quickly.
cue-626
Before long, he helped his mother buy her
freedom, though the price was very high.
cue-627
As he grew older, he went on longer and
longer trading trips into the countryside.
cue-628
In early 1885, he joined a group
traveling to the north bank of the Congo
cue-629
River, about 80 miles away.
cue-630
On the way, they crossed the large road
built by Stanley from Manyanga to the
cue-631
pool, which amazed them. On the other
side, they heard rumors about a railway
cue-632
being built, but no one really knew what
it was or what it would do. Some in the
cue-633
group had been to Boma and had seen the
big steamers there. People said, that's
cue-634
the thing.
cue-635
But they couldn't understand how those
steamers could ever travel over land.
cue-636
It seemed like magic.
cue-637
Still, they admitted that the white men
had a lot of ngangu, cleverness, and there
cue-638
was no telling what they might do.
cue-639
On the way back, they passed Ngombe,
cue-640
Wathan, where a new station was being set
up, moved from Manyanga.
cue-641
This was the first time Matula ever saw a
white man,
cue-642
though only from a distance,
cue-643
as they moved quickly through the area,
afraid of being cursed.
cue-644
Yet Matula was very impressed with the
white man's ngangu.
cue-645
He saw that the area around Ngombe was a
great place for trade, so he came back
cue-646
often with sheep, goats, pigs, and other
goods,
cue-647
though he stayed away from the station and
didn't go near it for about two more
cue-648
years. Then he came to sell sheep at
Vunda, about two hours away, and stopped
cue-649
by Nlemvo's place,
cue-650
Mr. Bentley's assistant in translation.
cue-651
To honor the visit, he killed a sheep and
gave the heart to Nlemvo as a sign of
cue-652
friendship.
cue-653
Not long before Nlemvo's own baptism, as a
committed follower of Christ, he spent a
cue-654
lot of time talking to Matula.
cue-655
But it was hard for Matula to believe that
the customs of his people were completely
cue-656
wrong, or to stop being suspicious of the
white man.
cue-657
In the morning, Nlemvo got Matula to join
him for prayers in a small grass prayer
cue-658
house.
cue-659
Everything felt strange to Matula. When
everyone closed their eyes to pray, he
cue-660
kept his open, afraid something might be
done to him when he wasn't looking.
cue-661
Still, the first seed had been planted and
the first step taken.
cue-662
He went on to Vunda with his sheep, where
he met Mr. Cameron, who was visiting for
cue-663
the day.
cue-664
Matula was surprised at the white man's
ngemda, friendliness, toward the people.
cue-665
They watched his every move, examined his
clothes and belongings, and were
cue-666
especially fascinated by how his food was
prepared and the table set.
cue-667
It was as if they had never seen anyone
eat before. They all crowded around to
cue-668
watch him use a knife and fork.
cue-669
When he gave out a few biscuits, which
were broken into pieces so everyone could
cue-670
have some, they were overjoyed and burst
into laughter.
cue-671
But when he started to talk about the one
in whose name he had come, it was like he
cue-672
had a disease.
cue-673
Everyone quickly went back to their
houses.
cue-674
Still, Matula remembered his kind face and
smile,
cue-675
and something began to grow in his heart.
cue-676
He started to feel that the white man was
a friend.
cue-677
The fear was gone, but most people still
rejected the new teaching,
cue-678
and that held Matula back for several
years.
cue-679
Soon after, Mr. Bentley began visiting the
Makuta district.After some time, the
cue-680
people of Tungwa decided to give him a boy
to help him, which surprised and pleased
cue-681
him. The chief said he would bring the boy
himself.
cue-682
When Matula heard about this, he chose to
join them on a trading trip.
cue-683
Everything went smoothly until they
reached Kinketa, about four or five hours
cue-684
from Ningombe. As they entered the town in
single file,
cue-685
Matula leading a sheep,
cue-686
a man stepped out demanding,
cue-687
"Pay the tax."
cue-688
They ignored him and walked on.
cue-689
Another man did the same, but they kept
going.
cue-690
Farther ahead, they were stopped by a
group with guns.
cue-691
Those in the back ran off. Matula was
caught and tied up, his sheep taken, and
cue-692
he was fined five hundred brass rods to
let the others continue. They had no
cue-693
choice but to pay. This happened just as
they were beginning to take interest in
cue-694
the white man's teachings, making it
especially unfortunate. Thankfully, the
cue-695
government later put an end to this
illegal taxation. In
cue-696
1890 and 1891, Mr. Bentley passed through
Matula's
cue-697
village,
cue-698
but Matula was away both times. It wasn't
until 1894, after
cue-699
Mr. Bentley returned from his time in
England, that they finally met again.
cue-700
Matula was just setting out on another
trading journey when he met Mr. Bentley
cue-701
heading toward Mongo.
cue-702
Matula had a brother suffering from a
serious, long-lasting ulcer,
cue-703
so he asked the missionary to come see
him.
cue-704
Matula gave up his planned journey and ran
back home to tell his family that the
cue-705
missionary was coming.
cue-706
Then he went out to meet him and led him
into the heart of the town.
cue-707
The missionary treated the ulcer, and
Matula was so pleased that he brought two
cue-708
large chickens as a matabish,
cue-709
gift.
cue-710
But Mr. Bentley, from past experience, had
learned to refuse such gifts because
cue-711
they often caused trouble.
cue-712
Some people thought the missionary was
like the fetish doctors who charged far
cue-713
too much, and others accused him of only
coming to take things without giving
cue-714
enough in return.
cue-715
So Mr. Bentley kindly declined the gift
and instead sat down to speak with the
cue-716
people who seemed ready to listen.
cue-717
Many had never heard the gospel before. He
told them about the God whose name they
cue-718
knew, the one who made them and everything
else, who gave rain and sunshine to help
cue-719
their food grow.
cue-720
This God always cared for them, yet they
were ungrateful, and their
cue-721
ways were wrong in his sight.
cue-722
He spoke of God's love in sending Jesus to
save them from their sins and to give
cue-723
them power to overcome evil and live holy
lives. He warned them of
cue-724
the coming judgment when all their
actions would be brought to account, for
cue-725
God sees everything. He urged them to turn
to Jesus, the only one
cue-726
who could save them.
cue-727
After he left, the people talked a lot
about what he said,
cue-728
but their old ways and customs were
precious to them.
cue-729
Why should they accept new teachings?
cue-730
They said these new things were just
kindoki,
cue-731
witchcraft, because their crops grew and
rain fell through the power of enkisi,
cue-732
fetishes.
cue-733
So they believed anything outside of
fetishism must be sorcery.
cue-734
In their thinking, everything was either
witchcraft or fetishism and nothing else.
cue-735
Yet one man in that crowd thought deeply
about what he had heard, and that man was
cue-736
Matula.
cue-737
This was another step forward for him.
cue-738
He now believed that the white men were
not only friendly, but that what they
cue-739
taught was good and worth remembering.
cue-740
He looked for chances to learn more. He
visited Bukusu, who had recently come back
cue-741
to Tungwa.
cue-742
Matula became very interested in him,
looked through his books, and wished he
cue-743
could read.
cue-744
From then on, he made up his mind to have
his own boy taught.
cue-745
When Matula returned, he told his friends
about his plan, but they were upset and
cue-746
tried hard to change his mind.
cue-747
Still, he made arrangements with two boys
to go with Mr. Bentley the next time he
cue-748
visited.
cue-749
However, Matula's mother found out and
secretly paid the boys to disappear as
cue-750
soon as Mr. Bentley arrived and not to
come back until he had left. A few weeks
cue-751
later, Mr. Bentley, remembering Matula's
interest, visited again.
cue-752
Matula told him he had two boys ready.
cue-753
Mr. Bentley stayed just one night, and in
the morning, Matula sent for the boys,
cue-754
but they were nowhere to be found.
cue-755
Realizing he had been tricked, he told Mr.
Bentley he would follow after him with at
cue-756
least one boy. Messengers were sent out
to search, and finally one boy was
cue-757
found just as Mr. Bentley was about to
leave the town.
cue-758
He was a big, cheerful boy of about
thirteen, wearing a new singlet Matula had
cue-759
given him and holding a rat in his hand.
cue-760
His name was Mankwenya.
cue-761
Matula told him he was going to become a
white black man, Mundele Anayombe,
cue-762
like Bukusu, and promised to visit him,
bringing money and chickens. That was
cue-763
enough to excite any boy.
cue-764
With a bright smile, Mankwenya said,
"Kiyambote," goodbye, to everyone and
cue-765
happily joined the small caravan on the
journey to Wathen, not worried at all
cue-766
about witches or sorcery.
cue-767
[upbeat music] Chapter Seven:
cue-768
Matula's Conversion.
cue-769
As soon as Mankwenya left Mongo, the
people began to turn against Matula.
cue-770
They now saw clearly that he had broken
from their ways and joined the white man's
cue-771
side. His mother cursed him and called
him a witch, so Matula stayed away from
cue-772
home as much as he could, going on trading
trips.
cue-773
He himself didn't fully understand the new
feelings stirring in his heart, but he
cue-774
couldn't turn away from them.
cue-775
Meanwhile, Mankwenya was doing fairly well
at school. He soon moved past learning
cue-776
the alphabet and joined the syllable
class. He was a cheerful, laughing boy
cue-777
with a good temper, and he quickly made
friends with everyone. He had arrived at
cue-778
the mission station just a few months
before my own arrival, and I remember the
cue-779
first time I saw him. He was wearing an
old, torn singlet, against the rules,
cue-780
which he kept trying to pull back on. His
face was full of mischief and fun.
cue-781
Watching him run with the other boys was
something to see.Because he was so fat and
cue-782
flat-footed, he was always the one left
behind.
cue-783
It was a real loss to the station when a
few months later, he went back to his town
cue-784
with Mr. Bentley and never returned. We
were all quite sorry,
cue-785
as we had grown fond of him. He was easily
influenced. Just as he had happily gone
cue-786
to the station, drawn by Matula's promises
of gifts, he stayed behind in his
cue-787
village when his mother tempted him with
her best dishes.
cue-788
He listened eagerly to her story, how she
had been mourning for him, afraid he had
cue-789
been eaten, and how sure she was that he
would be eaten if he went back.
cue-790
He didn't really believe her story about
being eaten,
cue-791
but he didn't like to see anyone sad.
cue-792
Her tears and pleas convinced him to stay
and not meet Mr. Bentley as planned.
cue-793
From our limited view, it seemed like a
disappointment,
cue-794
but in truth, it was something to be
thankful for. Matula didn't have the heart
cue-795
to fight his aunt
cue-796
a second time about Mankwenya,
cue-797
but he still deeply wanted to know all
that the boy had learned at Ngombe.
cue-798
The two of them often sat together,
talking for hours.
cue-799
Mankwenya did his best to tell Matula
about the great God he had heard of and
cue-800
about Jesus Christ, his Son.
cue-801
Matula tried hard to take in every word.
cue-802
Then, wherever Matula went, he would tell
others about the strange and wonderful
cue-803
things Mankwenya had shared with him.
cue-804
Matula often saw the boy studying his
cue-805
Mwelo Wazi,
cue-806
Gate of Knowledge, the first Congo reading
book,
cue-807
and he would sit next to him to learn.
cue-808
They agreed to hold their own little
school each day.
cue-809
Poor Mankwenya.
cue-810
This was not easy for him.
cue-811
In his cheerful and easygoing way, he had
forgotten some of the letters, so it was
cue-812
no surprise when P turned into B or D, and
M looked like
cue-813
W or N like U.
cue-814
Somehow even F got mixed up with T,
cue-815
so they didn't make much progress,
cue-816
but Matula felt they were moving forward.
cue-817
In the evenings, Matula would gather
everyone who was willing to come and sing
cue-818
together.
cue-819
Mankwenya taught them the simple songs he
had learned, like Jesus Loves Me
cue-820
or Follow, Follow, I Will Follow Jesus.
cue-821
Matula later said he couldn't guarantee
they sang correctly,
cue-822
but he was sure they sang with all their
hearts.
cue-823
He would walk about a mile in different
directions to hear if their singing
cue-824
carried through the evening air.
cue-825
If he couldn't hear it well, he would come
back and say,
cue-826
Shout louder. Raise your voices.
cue-827
If he could hear it clearly, he'd return
and say,
cue-828
Wambote Kikilu,
cue-829
-it is very good.
-And then they would sing it all over
cue-830
again.
cue-831
Is there any more touching picture than
this group of souls just stepping out of
cue-832
darkness into the first light of dawn?
cue-833
None of them truly understood the meaning
of the beautiful hymn they sang to the
cue-834
-tune of Jesus Loves Me.
-Jizu ntu zole.
cue-835
Nkand a nzambi nvovole wo. Yeto awonso
cue-836
tu anandi. Okutulundanga.
cue-837
Jizu ntu zolele bia. Elo ntu zolele. Jizu
ntu
cue-838
-zolele. Oyandi nkundi eto.
-Translation.
cue-839
Jesus, he is loving us.
cue-840
The book of God has told us this. Truly we
his people are. He
cue-841
keeps us with great care.
cue-842
Jesus, he is loving us. Yes, he is loving
us. Jesus,
cue-843
he is loving us.
cue-844
Our only friend is he.
cue-845
Everywhere Matula and his wife went, they
sang these simple hymns and shared with
cue-846
the people what they were learning.
cue-847
For a time, Matula stopped going on
trading trips so he could fully give
cue-848
himself to these new experiences.
cue-849
It's hard to say exactly when the
spiritual awakening of a soul truly
cue-850
begins. Matula himself wasn't sure when it
happened,
cue-851
but it was clear that God had started a
work of grace in his heart.
cue-852
Around that time, the chief of Makuta,
where Ponda had recently begun to teach,
cue-853
came to visit Mongo. He told Matula how he
had started learning to read,
cue-854
ABD, since the Congo language has no C.
cue-855
But he found that it led to more than just
reading. It brought him to the New
cue-856
Testament, Ekangu Diampa, which spoke
against drunkenness, adultery,
cue-857
lying, murder, and so on.
cue-858
Since he didn't want to give up these
things, he stopped learning and turned
cue-859
away from Christianity.
cue-860
Matula was still unsure about many things.
He didn't yet understand it all, but was
cue-861
trying to follow the little light he had.
cue-862
He knew that things like murder and
adultery were against God's teaching. He
cue-863
had even hated murder before ever hearing
about God. But he didn't yet realize that
cue-864
drunkenness also displeased God. So in
trying to encourage the chief of
cue-865
Makuta to keep learning and attending
prayers,
cue-866
Matula told him that he could still read
and pray while drinking all the palm wine
cue-867
he liked.
cue-868
The chief agreed, saying,
cue-869
All right, let's at least have some palm
wine.
cue-870
A calabash was brought, and both of them
drank quite a bit.
cue-871
Then Matula began to sing,
cue-872
not with the filthy songs of drunkenness,
but with the beautiful words of Tom
cue-873
Comber's hymn, set to the tune of Lord, a
Little Band and Lowly.
cue-874
Rousseau.
cue-875
Nzambi seto no
cue-876
kwa ankenda no matale nsi zero konso nsi
kwa
cue-877
nsoki yasibma tombe kingi kiabukowa.
Nzambi
cue-878
seseto u nkwa ankenda toma tale nsi zeto.
cue-879
Translation.
cue-880
God our Father, full of kindness, look
upon our country, every land which
cue-881
sin has cursed, and where deep darkness
still remains. God our Father,
cue-882
full of kindness, look upon our country.
cue-883
People thought Matula had gone mad. Who
had ever heard of a drunk man singing
cue-884
hymns?His name spread across the region,
and many came from far away
cue-885
just to see him.
cue-886
Eventually, he came to understand that
drunkenness was shameful and a serious sin
cue-887
before God, and he gave up drinking palm
wine.
cue-888
In this country, as in others, drunkenness
is a deep curse, but nearly every
cue-889
Christian on the Congo is a total
abstainer.
cue-890
Matula was slowly growing under the
guidance of the Holy Spirit,
cue-891
but the devil doesn't give up his servants
without a fight.
cue-892
He followed Matula closely and seemed to
win when Matula got drunk.
cue-893
But what must he have thought when that
same drunk man began singing a prayer to
cue-894
God the Father?
cue-895
Still, Satan believed he could win another
way. If he couldn't drag Matula down
cue-896
through drunkenness, he would use pride,
the greatest snare for many.
cue-897
Matula was becoming well known, and
stories of his actions spread through
cue-898
every town and market. Who could resist
such fame?
cue-899
But thank God, the devil does not win
every battle for the soul.
cue-900
The Holy Spirit had begun a great work in
Matula's heart, and it would not fail.
cue-901
To rescue Matula from his rising pride,
something too subtle for him to handle
cue-902
alone, he had to be brought low.
cue-903
For a while, it looked as though he had
completely given up his faith,
cue-904
and so it happened.
cue-905
Not long after the visit from the Makuta
chief, Matula's mother became very sick.
cue-906
A deep darkness came over him. The old
superstitions he had been shedding now
cue-907
clung to him more tightly than ever,
trying to hold him back.
cue-908
People said his mother had been bewitched.
cue-909
Matula became convinced that Manquenha was
the one who had done it. After all, he
cue-910
had brought these new teachings, which
many said were witchcraft.
cue-911
It was a terrible moment.
cue-912
Matula gathered the people and declared
that he believed the boy was a witch.
cue-913
He ordered the women not to go to the
market and forbade both them and Manquenha
cue-914
from leaving the village while his mother
was ill.
cue-915
And Matula, who once hated the crime of
killing someone accused of witchcraft, now
cue-916
made a horrifying threat.
cue-917
If his mother died, Manquenha would be
killed too. He commanded the boy to stop
cue-918
singing, stop teaching, and never again
speak about God's words.
cue-919
Many people supported him, glad to see
Matula returning, indeed going even
cue-920
further,
cue-921
into his old heathen ways.
cue-922
For several days, there was deep anxiety.
It seemed as though the devil might truly
cue-923
win.
cue-924
Matula's mother hovered between life and
death,
cue-925
but slowly she began to recover. This, for
a time, made
cue-926
Matula more confident in the old ways.
cue-927
Yet it was surely God's hand that kept him
from shedding blood, so that later, when
cue-928
he would face accusations, he could
truthfully say he had never murdered or
cue-929
even helped to kill anyone.
cue-930
In the months that followed, Matula
slipped back into his old ways. He stopped
cue-931
trying to learn, stopped singing, and
tried to forget about God entirely.
cue-932
To distract himself, he turned heavily to
slave dealing and resumed his former
cue-933
trading habits. He filled his time with
markets and the routines of his past,
cue-934
trying to silence the voice of conscience.
cue-935
One day, his trading brought him to
Makuta.
cue-936
The chief there welcomed him warmly and
praised him for giving up God's palaver.
cue-937
For the next few days, they threw
themselves into enjoying native life.
cue-938
His wife, Kento, came with him. She was,
without doubt, one of the most faithful
cue-939
and devoted women among the Congo people.
cue-940
The evening before they left, they heard
singing from the prayer group led by
cue-941
Ponde.
cue-942
They were drawn to it and went to listen.
cue-943
As they sat there, they were both deeply
convicted.
cue-944
God's Spirit stirred their hearts. They
wept bitterly as they remembered how they
cue-945
had once sung those very hymns with joy
and how happy they had been. That
cue-946
memory moved them to a firm decision. They
would seek these things again
cue-947
and nothing else.
cue-948
Matula's first step was to make peace with
Ponde. In that culture, this was a
cue-949
significant event, almost like a formal
engagement.
cue-950
Matula invited Ponde to visit his town,
and Ponde gladly accepted, soon arriving
cue-951
in Mongo. Matula was overjoyed. To honor
the occasion and confirm their
cue-952
friendship, he prepared a generous meal
with various foods and even boiled two
cue-953
chickens,
cue-954
a costly gesture. He also brought a large
sheep as a gift for Ponde, though Ponde
cue-955
wisely refused it to avoid gossip about
greed.
cue-956
This friendship between Matula and Ponde
became deep and lasting until Ponde's
cue-957
death in 1898, a story told by Meister
Bentley.
cue-958
After the meal, Matula gathered the people
again, saying he wanted to restart the
cue-959
teaching and singing now that Ponde was
with them.
cue-960
Many came to meet him, someone they had
known since childhood.
cue-961
Then followed a wonderful time of singing.
cue-962
-Matula later said,
-We only knew one or two hymns, but Ponde
cue-963
knew so many.
cue-964
Manquenha helped where he could, and the
rest just did their best,
cue-965
opening their mouths and copying the
sounds.
cue-966
What a sight it must have been,
cue-967
perhaps more pleasing to God than many
grand choirs dressed in fine clothes and
cue-968
singing polished music.
cue-969
For in that little group, there were
hearts stirred and lives awakened.
cue-970
They sang not for the music, but for what
the songs meant.
cue-971
From time to time, Ponde paused to explain
the words of the hymns. Then he
cue-972
shared the story of his own conversion and
how he had come to trust in Jesus.
cue-973
What a change it brings to life.
cue-974
Ponde spoke from personal experience, how
the message of Christ could turn a sullen
cue-975
man into someone kind and a quick-tempered
man into one who is gentle.
cue-976
This went far deeper than Matula had
imagined.
cue-977
He had understood that Christianity must
stop outward, obvious sins,
cue-978
but he hadn't thought of the everyday
faults, the quiet habits and inner
cue-979
struggles common to every person,
cue-980
as sins too, let alone that they should be
changed.He listened eagerly.
cue-981
He was learning more about Christ.
cue-982
Not only that Jesus saves from the
punishment of sin,
cue-983
but that he also frees from its power.
cue-984
Here before him stood someone he had known
since childhood,
cue-985
and now that man's life was completely
transformed.
cue-986
Matula was deeply impressed.
cue-987
Though his own pride was starting to be
humbled, he still struggled with fierce
cue-988
bursts of anger, a weakness that would
later bring him pain. But those
cue-989
days, which Matula now remembers with joy,
were days of peace before a coming
cue-990
storm.
cue-991
In that time, he learned much about God's
power, and a simple, firm faith was
cue-992
planted in him, a faith he has never lost.
cue-993
Even in his hardest trials, he could
always say with strong and sincere
cue-994
conviction...
cue-995
"God, my Father, knows."
cue-996
Chapter Eight: Troubles and Trials.
cue-997
Funerals in Congo are usually carried out
according to the customs of each town or
cue-998
district.
cue-999
Still, there are some common features,
especially when someone important dies.
cue-1000
The body is often smoked for several days
over a small fire, then wrapped in cloth,
cue-1001
sometimes only one or two pieces.
cue-1002
In this state, the body might be kept for
weeks, months, or even years.
cue-1003
This gives time for friends and relatives
to compete in bringing the largest gifts
cue-1004
or the most cloth for wrapping the body
before burial. For great chiefs, gunshots
cue-1005
are fired, drums and horns are played
almost non-stop, and the whole town
cue-1006
takes part in a feast. On the day of
burial, people come from all around. The
cue-1007
body, wrapped in many layers of cloth, is
buried along with nearly all the
cue-1008
possessions the person had in life.
cue-1009
Two or three years ago, the great chief of
this area died. While his body lay in
cue-1010
state, between fifty to one hundred goats
were killed, along with many chickens.
cue-1011
Around five hundred small kegs of
gunpowder were fired. His body was wrapped
cue-1012
until it was the size of a dining table.
About two hundred pieces of cloth, equal
cue-1013
to one thousand six hundred yards, were
buried with him, along with several heavy
cue-1014
ivory tusks and expensive leopard and wild
animal skins.
cue-1015
Every man hopes his funeral will be so
extravagant that people will talk about
cue-1016
the amount of wealth used,
cue-1017
and many begin saving for it from
childhood. On the day of the funeral,
cue-1018
during the feasting,
cue-1019
fights often break out, and knives are
sometimes drawn.
cue-1020
In this, they're not far behind the native
Irish in knowing how to hold a dramatic
cue-1021
wake.
cue-1022
Just a few days after the events of the
previous chapter, one of the mothers of
cue-1023
Matula's second wife died at Nzundu.
cue-1024
Matula went to show respect. He brought
generous gifts and several pieces of cloth
cue-1025
and stayed for the burial.
cue-1026
The people were surprised that he wouldn't
drink palm wine, a habit he had given up
cue-1027
after becoming friends with Ponda.
cue-1028
He explained the change in his heart and
how much better it was to follow God and
cue-1029
leave the old ways behind.
cue-1030
But the people didn't listen closely.
cue-1031
They were sure something was wrong with
him.
cue-1032
Still, they didn't forget his words
cue-1033
and would remember them later to use
against him.
cue-1034
The day after the burial, Matula was on
his way back to Mongo and stopped at a
cue-1035
market along the road.
cue-1036
While he waited, a drunk man from Nzundu
approached him and asked for a piece of
cue-1037
cloth. Matula refused, knowing that if he
gave in, all his
cue-1038
possessions would soon be taken by lazy
relatives. But the man had been
cue-1039
encouraged to provoke Matula.
cue-1040
He followed him home, and after some
insistence, Matula gave him just enough
cue-1041
cloth to cover himself.
cue-1042
Instead of being grateful, the man
insulted Matula, calling him stingy and
cue-1043
accusing him of using the new god's
palavers to bewitch people and get rich.
cue-1044
His anger boiled over, and he struck
Matula on the head with a stick.
cue-1045
Caught off guard and overcome with rage,
Matula rushed inside, grabbed his gun,
cue-1046
and fired at the man,
cue-1047
but missed. He immediately regretted it.
The man fled, yelling to his
cue-1048
people that Matula had shot him. He said
nothing about the provocation. This was
cue-1049
enough to stir the whole town to fury.
Armed with guns, they stormed over to
cue-1050
Mongo.
cue-1051
As the women fled into the forest and only
a few men remained, Matula tried to
cue-1052
resolve the situation by talking and
offering to pay a fine,
cue-1053
but they refused to listen.
cue-1054
They captured him and locked him in a
house, planning to kill him that evening.
cue-1055
They believed the house was secure. It
didn't have the usual second exit and sat
cue-1056
down to watch.
cue-1057
Matula prayed desperately, comforting
himself with the words, "God knows."
cue-1058
Searching for a way out, he noticed a
corner of the gable end that wasn't
cue-1059
tightly bound.
cue-1060
Quietly lifting one of the small cross
rods and parting the grass, he slipped
cue-1061
through into the thick woods behind the
house.
cue-1062
There, he found a small trail leading to a
river. He walked in the water to avoid
cue-1063
leaving footprints.
cue-1064
Soon after, his captors checked the house
and were stunned to find it empty.
cue-1065
"He must have used witchcraft,"
cue-1066
they exclaimed. "What a witch he is."
cue-1067
They believed he had been too scared to
run, as many had been before.
cue-1068
They called out,
cue-1069
but no one answered.
cue-1070
Then they looted everything they could
find and searched for the women.
cue-1071
Eventually, they found Maluvunu, Matula's
sister, and took her with them.
cue-1072
When they reached Nzundu, they fired guns
and wasted powder to celebrate her capture
cue-1073
and stir courage for a planned attack on
Mongo the next day.
cue-1074
They expected Matula's friends would try
to rescue her.
cue-1075
Meanwhile, Matula remained in hiding.
cue-1076
He barely slept that night.
cue-1077
When he heard the gunfire from Nzundu, he
guessed they had returned,
cue-1078
but he could only wonder what they had
done to his town. The next morning, as
cue-1079
Matula cautiously made his way back toward
Mongo, he spotted the Nzundu people
cue-1080
marching toward his town.
cue-1081
-He boldly called out...
-"Wait for me, and I will go along with
cue-1082
you."
cue-1083
Hearing Matula's voice suddenly and not
seeing him, they were seized with panic.
cue-1084
In fear and confusion, they all turned and
fled back to Nzundu.
cue-1085
Once they were gone,
cue-1086
Matula rose from hiding and continued his
journey.
cue-1087
As he neared Mongo, he met his relatives
armed and ready to march, determined to
cue-1088
rescue Malovunu and avenge the attack on
Matula.
cue-1089
He tried to stop them, urging peace and
saying it was wrong to fight.
cue-1090
He encouraged them to find another way to
settle the conflict,
cue-1091
but they wouldn't listen and went on
without him.
cue-1092
Warfare in Congo tends to be more dramatic
than deadly. A simple rain shower
cue-1093
can delay a battle indefinitely. What
they truly seek is noise. If enough
cue-1094
gunpowder is fired, they call it a great
battle.
cue-1095
Since no one wants to be shot, everyone
tries to stay out of harm's way.
cue-1096
Injuries, let alone deaths, are rare.
cue-1097
These two groups met the next day, and
after much firing, one man on the Nzundu
cue-1098
side was slightly wounded. Blood had been
drawn, so the next day they tried to
cue-1099
even the score.
cue-1100
This time, they succeeded beyond their
intent. One of Matula's people was killed.
cue-1101
That put an end to the fighting,
cue-1102
for now. They paused to figure out what
had caused the man's death. Tragically,
cue-1103
the people still believed in witchcraft
and accused Matula of murder.
cue-1104
Even though he wasn't present at the
battle, they blamed him.
cue-1105
To a reasonable person, it would make no
sense. Why would Matula want one of his
cue-1106
own men dead?
cue-1107
But they reasoned that because he had
caused the war, he was responsible.
cue-1108
Also, they feared that if they didn't
accuse him, he might demand heavy damages
cue-1109
from the man who had killed his relative.
cue-1110
So the war stopped for the time being, and
the focus shifted entirely to Matula.
cue-1111
They labeled him a witch and called for
his death.
cue-1112
Now he faced a different kind of battle,
cue-1113
not one fought with guns, but a spiritual
war against the deep darkness that
cue-1114
sought to destroy him.
cue-1115
[upbeat music] Chapter Nine:
cue-1116
Persecution.
cue-1117
Now everyone remembered everything Matula
had ever said about God's palavers,
cue-1118
and rightly so, for he had never hidden
the light he had received, and he had
cue-1119
never been ashamed to speak of Christ
before others.
cue-1120
But to most of the natives,
cue-1121
these teachings were sorcery.
cue-1122
So when poverty, sickness, and death
spread among his relatives, they blamed
cue-1123
him.
cue-1124
Unless he gave up these new beliefs and
returned to his old ways, they said, he
cue-1125
would have to be killed.
cue-1126
Most of his old friends abandoned him and
joined those who accused him of being a
cue-1127
witch.
cue-1128
One old chief, who had once been a close
friend to Matula, now decided it was his
cue-1129
duty to lead the first attack on him.
cue-1130
The chief was cunning and laid his plan
carefully.
cue-1131
He announced a great fetish ceremony to
renew the power of his nkisi for hunting
cue-1132
and fighting.
cue-1133
But secretly, he told his people the real
purpose was to kill Matula when he
cue-1134
came. The plan was to pretend the chief
was sick or come up with another excuse to
cue-1135
summon Matula.
cue-1136
Then they would kill him. Everyone
involved was sworn to secrecy. Everything
cue-1137
was prepared, and they waited for the
appointed day.
cue-1138
But there was one true friend among them
who pretended loyalty to the chief.
cue-1139
He flattered him and asked for permission
to go to the market to fetch some palm
cue-1140
wine.
cue-1141
Taking a roundabout route, he stopped at
Mongo to warn Matula not to go, no matter
cue-1142
what message came.
cue-1143
That evening, a messenger arrived saying
the chief was seriously ill and wanted to
cue-1144
see Matula.
cue-1145
But Matula's brother would not allow him
to go.
cue-1146
Instead, he went himself
cue-1147
and found the chief genuinely very sick.
cue-1148
He had suddenly fallen ill.
cue-1149
The next day, the very day he had planned
Matula's murder, the chief died. It
cue-1150
was a direct intervention by God.
cue-1151
Let others explain it how they wish.
cue-1152
Not long after, the older brother who had
gone in Matula's place died.
cue-1153
Before his death, he gathered his brothers
and gave each a stick, saying,
cue-1154
"It is your place to settle matters and
fight if needed,
cue-1155
but leave Matula alone.
cue-1156
Let him live in peace, trade, and pray to
God,"
cue-1157
Sambila Nzambi.
cue-1158
In Congo, the words of a dying man are
deeply respected, even more than in many
cue-1159
other cultures.
cue-1160
So Matula's immediate family largely left
him in peace. However, his enemies, who
cue-1161
came from the senior branch of his family,
only saw more reason to persecute him.
cue-1162
How could they attack him now?
cue-1163
They had already tried murder twice, and
each time he had escaped in astonishing
cue-1164
ways.
cue-1165
So these servants of darkness invented a
charge of adultery against him and four of
cue-1166
his younger brothers. They found a woman
willing to accept a large bribe to lie,
cue-1167
and she accused Matula. He was brought
before two powerful chiefs, one
cue-1168
the chief of the woman, the other a
leader who had recently lost many people
cue-1169
to illness.
cue-1170
The first fined him forty men for the
deaths, and the second fined him three
cue-1171
hundred thousand nzimbu, roughly
twenty-six pounds, for adultery.
cue-1172
It was an absurd judgment, but there was
no way to fight it. His enemies believed
cue-1173
they had finally succeeded, that Matula
would be sold into slavery.
cue-1174
Matula feared the same and told his wife,
Kento, to return to her people for her
cue-1175
safety.
cue-1176
But she replied, like someone from
scripture she had never heard of, "Where
cue-1177
you go, I will go. If you go into slavery,
so will I."
cue-1178
Nothing could persuade her to leave him.
To the surprise of his enemies, Matula
cue-1179
began doing all he could to pay the fine.
cue-1180
He managed to pay half the money and
surrender five men. He also had many sheep
cue-1181
scattered across the country that he
hoped not to lose.
cue-1182
It became clear he would likely succeed in
paying the full fine.
cue-1183
So his enemies began plotting again,
cue-1184
this time determined to create a new
accusation that would surely cost him his
cue-1185
life.
cue-1186
One man remembered that some years
earlier, a woman had died under unusual
cue-1187
circumstances, though it was actually
smallpox that killed her.Now they
cue-1188
planned to use that incident against
Matula. Their goal was to accuse him of
cue-1189
murder.
cue-1190
The state had recently arrived in Tumba,
about six hours away, and had begun
cue-1191
enforcing new laws,
cue-1192
one of which threatened death by hanging
for anyone convicted of murder.
cue-1193
So if Matula could be formally charged and
handed over to the authorities, his
cue-1194
enemies believed they could finally be rid
of him without laying a hand on him
cue-1195
themselves.
cue-1196
They bound him and took him to Tumba as a
criminal, accusing him of murder.
cue-1197
At the beginning of eighteen ninety-six,
cue-1198
Tumba was a wilderness.
cue-1199
By midsummer, it had become a bustling
construction site, and by the end of the
cue-1200
year, it had transformed into a thriving
town.
cue-1201
Traders' shops sprang up like mushrooms,
an almost unbelievable number for the
cue-1202
area.
cue-1203
A residence was built for the
commissioner, along with government
cue-1204
buildings and barracks for over fifty
soldiers.
cue-1205
Some readers may recall Tumba as the site
of one of the most heartbreaking stories
cue-1206
in the history of the Congo mission.
cue-1207
Mr. Stephen started the station there in
May eighteen ninety-six.
cue-1208
At the end of the year, when Mr. and Mrs.
Popel arrived, he moved upriver to Yacusu
cue-1209
for further work.
cue-1210
Mr. Popel struggled with illness for
months and died the following April.
cue-1211
Just six weeks later, his wife died too
and was buried beside him.
cue-1212
Early that same year, Matula was taken to
Tumba to stand trial, accused of
cue-1213
murder and adultery. At the time, the
judge only visited the town occasionally
cue-1214
and depended heavily on a native
interpreter, who was easily bribed. In
cue-1215
fact, most non-Christian natives were
known to accept bribes as readily as
cue-1216
flowers receive sunlight.
cue-1217
Skilled speakers and often bold liars,
they could convincingly make evil appear
cue-1218
good and twist an innocent person's
character into that of a villain.
cue-1219
Their performance could deceive even the
sharpest defense counsel unfamiliar with
cue-1220
their ways.
cue-1221
Matula's enemies prepared their case
carefully. Along with the murder charge
cue-1222
involving two women, they revived the old
accusation of adultery, though they
cue-1223
didn't emphasize it as much.
cue-1224
Still, the woman was present to testify
against him.
cue-1225
They quickly found the interpreter and
offered him a generous bribe, promising
cue-1226
more if Matula were sentenced to death.
cue-1227
A few days later, Matula's case was
brought before the court. The interpreter
cue-1228
presented the charges to the judge and
gave a detailed account based entirely on
cue-1229
the version from Matula's accusers of the
events and of Matula's supposed character.
cue-1230
Witnesses were called, all of them false,
to support the accusations.
cue-1231
Their testimony painted Matula as an
umpwimbihi, a wild, lawless man,
cue-1232
and claimed the country would be better
without him. Then came the defense
cue-1233
witnesses. They could only speak of
Matula's character and say they believed
cue-1234
he was innocent. But under
cross-examination, it came out that Matula
cue-1235
had been fined on several occasions and
was seen by local chiefs as an umpwimbulu,
cue-1236
a troublemaker. Their testimony, instead
of helping, strengthened the
cue-1237
prosecution's case.
cue-1238
Things looked very bad for Matula. His
enemies were rejoicing.
cue-1239
Then the judge called on Matula to speak
for himself.
cue-1240
Calmly and plainly, Matula gave a truthful
account of his relationship with those
cue-1241
who were accusing him.
cue-1242
He ended by saying...
cue-1243
"My Lord, these people have sought my life
and have tried to kill me many times.
cue-1244
God knows I am innocent of these charges.
cue-1245
I have never killed nor helped to kill
cue-1246
anyone."
cue-1247
The judge was deeply impressed by his
honest and simple words. He found himself
cue-1248
torn. Should he accept one man's word
against many witnesses?
cue-1249
He knew his interpreter believed Matula
was guilty.
cue-1250
During the lunch break, the judge weighed
his decision. He was scheduled to leave
cue-1251
the next morning.
cue-1252
Should he sentence Matula to be hanged
now?
cue-1253
No, he decided not to. Instead, he would
give Matula a chance to prove his
cue-1254
innocence.
cue-1255
When court resumed, the judge called
Matula forward and said...
cue-1256
"Your case is very serious, but as you
said, God knows whether you are innocent
cue-1257
or not. I'm going to release you for a few
months, but when you are summoned again,
cue-1258
you must come. And unless you bring more
evidence of your innocence, the judgment
cue-1259
will go against you."
cue-1260
Matula thanked the judge and, much to the
anger of his enemies, walked out of the
cue-1261
court a free man, at least until the judge
returned.
cue-1262
When Matula returned to Mungo, his wives
and sisters, exhausted from crying and
cue-1263
having given him up for dead, were
overjoyed to see him alive.
cue-1264
But their joy quickly faded when he told
them he would have to return to Tumba.
cue-1265
He saw no way to strengthen his defense.
cue-1266
His accusers were confused by the delay.
They began to worry that Matula might
cue-1267
escape judgment altogether.
cue-1268
Not willing to leave the matter in the
state's hands, they resumed harassing him.
cue-1269
They sent messengers again and again to
see if he was still in town, though none
cue-1270
dared approach too closely, fearing he was
in league with evil spirits.
cue-1271
Still, they resolved to form a strong
party to capture him, and a friend warned
cue-1272
Matula that they would arrive in two days.
cue-1273
Poor Matula.
cue-1274
Though he believed God was with him, he
felt weary from being constantly hunted.
cue-1275
In that moment of deep need, he longed for
someone,
cue-1276
anyone, to stand by him and help.
cue-1277
But who was there?
cue-1278
Pond, though faithful, had no influence to
protect him.
cue-1279
Matula feared that even going to him would
only stir up more anger from his enemies.
cue-1280
It was a time of great testing for his
faith. If he turned his back on
cue-1281
Christianity and gave up all he had to his
accusers, they would let him live.
cue-1282
The question now stood before him.
cue-1283
Should he give in to save his life?
cue-1284
Chapter 10: Exodus.
cue-1285
The temptation was very real. Unless he
made peace with his enemies, there seemed
cue-1286
to be no hope of escape.At least from a
human perspective.
cue-1287
He had only two days to decide. He thought
and prayed deeply about it.
cue-1288
Then, as if by revelation, the thought
came,
cue-1289
"What about the missionaries?"
cue-1290
At that, he danced with joy.
cue-1291
Why hadn't he thought of it before?
cue-1292
To us, it seems strange, and must be
counted among those odd lapses that happen
cue-1293
in almost every life.
cue-1294
As soon as the idea came, he resolved to
act on it. He told Manquenha to go ahead
cue-1295
and let Mr. Bentley know he was coming,
bringing with him as many of his people as
cue-1296
would join.
cue-1297
Then he visited his closest relatives and
shared his decision to go and settle at
cue-1298
Ngombe. His two wives agreed right away,
as did most of his family, though
cue-1299
some preferred to stay home rather than
move to an unfamiliar place.
cue-1300
They packed quickly, prepared food for the
journey, and were ready to leave the
cue-1301
night before his enemies were expected to
capture him.
cue-1302
They set off in the dark,
cue-1303
a small group of thirty-seven, including
his nearly sixty-year-old mother and a
cue-1304
baby just a few months old.
cue-1305
Some had severe leg ulcers, one was lame,
and another hadn't walked in weeks.
cue-1306
What a mixed group they were. It's a
mystery how they managed to travel the
cue-1307
sixty miles without accident or injury.
Surely God was with them. They
cue-1308
walked all night and rested near the
railway at dawn.
cue-1309
While eating breakfast, someone shouted,
"Soldiers!"
cue-1310
The women ran into the tall grass, and the
men looked frightened.
cue-1311
But it was a false alarm. Just one soldier
passed by, not recognizing them, and
cue-1312
simply greeted them with a "Good morning"
before moving on.
cue-1313
They walked a little farther along the
railway and met some white men who asked
cue-1314
where they were going. They said they were
heading to their friends at Ngombe.
cue-1315
"Oui, oui, to Monsieur Bentley,"
cue-1316
the men replied, then continued on their
way.
cue-1317
The journey from there was exhausting, up
hills and down valleys, through marshes
cue-1318
and swamps, until they finally reached
Kinkete, the place where Matula had paid
cue-1319
taxes back in 1891.
cue-1320
They rested there for a while. The locals
urged Matula to settle among them and even
cue-1321
returned the unjust tax they had taken.
cue-1322
But since there were no Christians there,
and he did not feel safe among others,
cue-1323
he refused.
cue-1324
Still, one or two of his group stayed
behind for a time.
cue-1325
About an hour from Kinkete lived
Selulundi, one of the most remarkable and
cue-1326
upright chiefs in the area. He knew Matula
well and tried to persuade him to settle
cue-1327
with him.
cue-1328
But Matula was eager to be near the white
missionary. However, he left the weaker
cue-1329
ones with Selulundi and continued the
journey with the rest to Ngombe, about
cue-1330
four hours further.
cue-1331
Matula was not disappointed in the welcome
he and his group received.
cue-1332
He immediately felt that, as far as human
help could reach, the missionary would do
cue-1333
all he could for them.
cue-1334
So he looked for a place and began
building a home.
cue-1335
A few days later, Matula went back for the
rest of his large family, who had stayed
cue-1336
behind to rest. He found that one of his
sisters had given birth to a child,
cue-1337
a bright little girl who now runs happily
around the station.
cue-1338
To his surprise, he also met nine of his
brothers who hadn't been in Mongo when he
cue-1339
left. When they heard where he had gone,
they decided to follow and settle with
cue-1340
him.
cue-1341
This was a great encouragement and showed
how much they trusted him.
cue-1342
The next day, they all set out for Ngombe
and arrived in the evening,
cue-1343
feeling they had finally found a place of
peace and safety,
cue-1344
free from the threat of enemies.
cue-1345
It was a great joy for us to welcome such
a large group to the little village of
cue-1346
Vyanga Vyanga, named after Tom Comber, now
being built just outside our
cue-1347
grounds.
cue-1348
We were especially glad because we want
the village to grow with new people rather
cue-1349
than just those already at the station,
to bring fresh energy and avoid forming a
cue-1350
closed circle that might hinder rather
than help.
cue-1351
What Matula did was a courageous act. He
had received a call,
cue-1352
just as clearly as Abraham long ago,
cue-1353
"Leave your country, your people, and your
father's house."
cue-1354
And didn't he obey that call just as
faithfully?
cue-1355
It was no small thing to place all his
trust in a missionary, someone he had been
cue-1356
taught to see as an enemy of his people.
cue-1357
Some might say he simply chose the lesser
of two evils.
cue-1358
But could that be?
cue-1359
If he had stayed in Mongo,
cue-1360
only he would have been killed.
cue-1361
But by leaving, he placed himself and all
his loved ones in the hands of God's
cue-1362
servants.
cue-1363
It was a pure, simple, and honest faith,
and God has greatly blessed
cue-1364
him for it.
cue-1365
They arrived near the end of the wet
season, a poor time to start planting, but
cue-1366
a good time to begin building. Everyone
threw themselves eagerly into the task of
cue-1367
creating a new village.
cue-1368
During the remaining rainy days, the women
worked at digging and planting manioc,
cue-1369
while the men gathered sticks and grass
for constructing houses. It was a very
cue-1370
busy season. We supported them as best we
could, allowing them to buy food from our
cue-1371
daily stock when they couldn't get enough
from the local people. Yet they never
cue-1372
became too busy to miss the daily prayer
meetings.
cue-1373
All of them came regularly, and for us,
having over forty people join in daily
cue-1374
worship was a great encouragement.
cue-1375
It brought real joy to see them grow more
attentive, and over time, to
cue-1376
witness many of them openly take their
stand for the Lord.
cue-1377
But I am getting ahead of the story.
cue-1378
By mid-August, all their houses were built
and their gardens ready for planting, a
cue-1379
record time for natives in the Congo.
cue-1380
During these months, Matula remained
surprisingly calm and cheerful. The women
cue-1381
would sometimes break down in tears,
fearing he might have to return to Tumba
cue-1382
to face the judge and his accusers.
cue-1383
There still seemed no way to strengthen
his case to prove his innocence.
cue-1384
We, of course, could only speak to the
character we had observed.But Matula never
cue-1385
became discouraged. He saw clear signs of
God's help and blessing.
cue-1386
Being innocent, he firmly believed that
God would one day reveal the truth.
cue-1387
It was this confidence that gave him
peace.
cue-1388
Chapter Eleven: Revisiting His People.
cue-1389
From the time Matula arrived at Ngombe, he
worked hard to make his people happy and
cue-1390
comfortable.
cue-1391
As we've seen, by mid-August, they were
well settled. Then his thoughts turned
cue-1392
from those who were safe to those who were
still in danger.
cue-1393
He didn't know how long he himself would
be spared. He could be summoned to Tumba
cue-1394
at any time, and it seemed there could
only be one outcome.
cue-1395
But this he knew,
cue-1396
if he were hanged, his enemies would steal
everything he had left behind in Mongo
cue-1397
and secretly sell his closest relatives
into slavery.
cue-1398
Longing to protect them physically, but
even more spiritually, he decided to
cue-1399
return once more to the place of his
trials and make another effort to save his
cue-1400
people.
cue-1401
When word spread that he was going back to
Mongo, his friends tried hard to change
cue-1402
his mind. His poor old mother clung to him
and begged him with tears not to risk it
cue-1403
again.
cue-1404
To them, it seemed like a sure path to
death.
cue-1405
But like Paul, he would not be persuaded
to turn back.
cue-1406
Two of his brothers went with him.
cue-1407
After two days of good travel, they
arrived on the evening of the third day
cue-1408
and quietly entered the house of a friend.
cue-1409
In the morning, when he went out, his
relatives, who never expected to see him
cue-1410
again,
cue-1411
were overjoyed. They ran about shouting,
"Matula has returned!"
cue-1412
But he cautioned them not to make too much
noise. He told them why he had come and
cue-1413
pleaded with them to leave everything and
come hear the Nsangu Zambote, the good
cue-1414
news, at the mission station.
cue-1415
But they refused.
cue-1416
"No, no,"
cue-1417
they said. "Not us.
cue-1418
We're living in the abundance you fools
ran away from.
cue-1419
There are plenty of gardens, goats, sheep,
and chickens.
cue-1420
We're not going."
cue-1421
He warned them that if he was killed, they
might be sold into slavery.
cue-1422
But like Lot's sons-in-law, they mocked
him.
cue-1423
As is common among natives, they only
thought of the present moment.
cue-1424
They took quite literally our Lord's
words, "Do not be anxious about tomorrow.
cue-1425
Sufficient unto the day is the evil
thereof."
cue-1426
They made no distinction between being
overanxious and simply being prepared.
cue-1427
To them, worry of any kind was pointless.
cue-1428
They chose to live one day at a time,
cue-1429
carefree, yes, but not without
consequence.
cue-1430
Matula was not there long before word
spread that he had returned.
cue-1431
People came to see him and accused him of
betraying them to the white men at Ngombe.
cue-1432
Mr. Bentley happened to be in the area at
the time, so they were too afraid to harm
cue-1433
Matula.
cue-1434
Still, he knew he needed to act quickly.
He wanted to take a few of his sheep with
cue-1435
him, but found only nine.
cue-1436
Many had already been stolen and sold.
cue-1437
He asked one of his brothers to lead the
sheep ahead.
cue-1438
When his enemies heard this, they went
ahead of him and set fire to the tall
cue-1439
grass in a narrow, enclosed area. The
sheep panicked and ran through the
cue-1440
flames. One died, and the rest were badly
singed. Grass
cue-1441
fires occasionally lead to deaths, though
not often.
cue-1442
In 1901, a woman and her child were burned
alive.
cue-1443
However, the wider roads enforced by the
government have helped prevent such
cue-1444
tragedies. It became clear that Matula's
enemies were still very active,
cue-1445
so he gathered his people again and
pleaded with them not to remain behind.
cue-1446
After much discussion, they took a vote.
cue-1447
Many who just days earlier had said, "We
will not go,"
cue-1448
now voted eagerly to leave the hostile
region.
cue-1449
This change of heart, typical of their
shifting feelings, was prompted by
cue-1450
whatever seemed most urgent at the moment.
A group of them soon left, but Matula
cue-1451
and his two companions stayed behind.
cue-1452
He still hoped to speak once more with
those who had been persecuting him and
cue-1453
try to make peace, for he had learned to
love even his enemies, a hard
cue-1454
lesson for even the most mature
Christians.
cue-1455
He went to see Ponde and asked for advice.
cue-1456
There he saw the work progressing well.
The people of Makuta were eagerly
cue-1457
learning, and it lifted his spirits. It
made him long even more for the people of
cue-1458
his own town to desire the same knowledge.
cue-1459
After discussing the matter with Ponde,
they decided to return together and try to
cue-1460
bring back one or two boys from Mongo to
be trained at the mission station.
cue-1461
This was their way of showing their zeal
to help and save the people.
cue-1462
Whether their effort was guided by wisdom
or not, readers may judge for themselves.
cue-1463
They returned to Mongo, full of love for
the people and a deep desire to help
cue-1464
them. Both friends and enemies gathered to
welcome Ponde.
cue-1465
Then they spoke to them about God's love,
how He cares for us and sent His Son Jesus
cue-1466
to show that love by dying for us and
bearing our sins in His own body
cue-1467
so that even the worst sinner might be
saved through Him.
cue-1468
Matula, with tears in his eyes, shared how
he now believed and spoke of
cue-1469
all the good news he had heard at Ngombe.
cue-1470
He told them he held no bitterness in his
heart against them and fully forgave them
cue-1471
for how they had treated him.
cue-1472
He pleaded with them to turn from their
evil ways and seek God.
cue-1473
He also spoke of how the people at Makuta
were growing in knowledge and gaining
cue-1474
wisdom, and how it would be good if they
too sent some boys to the mission station,
cue-1475
boys who could return and teach them like
Ponde was doing. The people listened with
cue-1476
great interest and attention. Matula was
convinced their hearts were softening.
cue-1477
They spoke openly afterward and promised
to send a boy or two back with him to be
cue-1478
trained.
cue-1479
That evening, Ponde departed, feeling very
pleased with the outcome of the visit.
cue-1480
But had he known what was about to happen
to Matula, he would surely have stayed
cue-1481
until his friend had safely returned to
cue-1482
Ngombe.Chapter
cue-1483
12:
cue-1484
Treachery.
cue-1485
The morning after Ponda left, some of the
locals came to Matula and asked when he
cue-1486
planned to return to Ngombe.
cue-1487
He told them he would go the next day.
They then invited him to Mbanza, the main
cue-1488
village of Mongo.
cue-1489
That afternoon, saying they had arranged
to send four boys with him.
cue-1490
Two were ready, and the other two would
follow later. Matula was overjoyed.
cue-1491
In his simple faith, he truly believed
they were beginning to change.
cue-1492
He thanked God for what he saw as a sign
of his blessing.
cue-1493
That afternoon, he went with his two
companions.
cue-1494
When they entered the chief's compound,
they were surprised to see a large group
cue-1495
of people armed with guns, knives, and
sticks.
cue-1496
Matula realized he had been betrayed, but
he sat down among them, trying to remain
cue-1497
calm, and began talking with them.
cue-1498
They asked questions about the white man
and the white man's God.
cue-1499
As Matula answered, telling them again of
God's love and his own love for them,
cue-1500
murmuring rose among the crowd.
cue-1501
They couldn't understand such selfless
love.
cue-1502
"Yes,"
cue-1503
some said,
cue-1504
"that's why our people are dying. Matula
is selling them all to the white man, who
cue-1505
takes them away by some secret means."
cue-1506
"We must get rid of him,"
cue-1507
others said. "Let's take him to the river
and kill him."
cue-1508
"No," one objected.
cue-1509
"There are witches there. He might
escape."
cue-1510
These things they whispered among
themselves.
cue-1511
-Then one bold man said aloud ...
-"Well, Matula, what you've told us is
cue-1512
good, and we want to learn too. We have
two boys up the river. Let's go and fetch
cue-1513
them."
cue-1514
Everyone agreed, and Matula and his
companions went along.
cue-1515
They passed through a wooded area to a
lonely house, where they stopped to rest
cue-1516
and called for the boys.
cue-1517
They called repeatedly and even pretended
to go fetch them, but it was all a trick.
cue-1518
No boys ever came.
cue-1519
Meanwhile, Matula and his two friends sat
under the eaves of the house and began to
cue-1520
read from their Mivelo Azai,
cue-1521
New Testaments.
cue-1522
But this only enraged the crowd.
cue-1523
To them, those books held the names of all
they believed Matula had sold.
cue-1524
One man jumped up and struck Matula on the
head. He stood up, but couldn't defend
cue-1525
himself as another man stabbed him in the
forehead. Blood gushed down his face.
cue-1526
His two friends ran, shouting, "Matula is
murdered!"
cue-1527
The others then stripped him of his
clothes, bound him with ropes, fastened a
cue-1528
forked stick around his neck, and led him
away in this shameful condition.
cue-1529
At first, Matula could hardly stand, and
blood nearly blinded him.
cue-1530
"Ah," he said,
cue-1531
"God forgive you.
cue-1532
Why do you want to kill me?
cue-1533
I am going to die, but I'm not afraid. If
you kill me, you will suffer.
cue-1534
Some of you won't even be allowed to bury
your own mothers."
cue-1535
Referring to one of the greatest tragedies
in their culture.
cue-1536
But they answered ...
cue-1537
"You've killed and eaten so many. Think of
all those who died because of you.
cue-1538
Why should you live? A traitor like you
doesn't deserve to live."
cue-1539
He replied
cue-1540
-...
-"You accuse me of killing Luvuma, Nzevo,
cue-1541
and my mother, Mundele, but they are alive
and well at Ngombe.
cue-1542
As for the others who have died, it was by
God's will."
cue-1543
They refused to listen.
cue-1544
They dragged him to a small river.
cue-1545
There, he begged them to kill him.
cue-1546
As he crossed the water, he stumbled over
a stone.
cue-1547
They tied another stick around his neck
and pulled him up the other side. Then
cue-1548
they led him to another village.
cue-1549
The chief there, an old friend, pretended
to object, saying ...
cue-1550
"Don't kill him here. I don't want to see
blood."
cue-1551
When Matula begged for a piece of cloth to
cover himself, the chief refused.
cue-1552
"No," he said. "Take him away."
cue-1553
Matula cried and pleaded to be killed then
and there, but they ignored him.
cue-1554
Others came to help drag him down into a
deep valley, where they tied him to a
cue-1555
tree. Some ran off to fetch a chief and
others to approve his execution.
cue-1556
Two chiefs and four men remained, sitting
around a small fire. To them, Matula,
cue-1557
though weak and suffering, tried to speak.
cue-1558
"Now I am dying," he said, "but I am not
afraid.
cue-1559
I rejoice, for when I die, I go to God.
cue-1560
You cannot kill me unless God allows it."
cue-1561
He begged them to repent.
cue-1562
-Their only response was ...
-"Let's have something to drink."
cue-1563
One had brought a large calabash of palm
wine, and they sat drinking, trying to get
cue-1564
drunk, while Matula, beaten and bleeding,
watched them in pity.
cue-1565
What a scene! It brings to mind the
suffering of our Lord Jesus.
cue-1566
Yet thank God, there are still those
willing to suffer for his name.
cue-1567
The messengers returned, but they hadn't
found those most involved in the case.
cue-1568
-"What shall we do?"
-One asked.
cue-1569
-"Let's sell him,"
-Suggested someone.
cue-1570
-"No,"
-Others replied.
cue-1571
"That will only cause more problems later.
Better to kill him. Let's take him to
cue-1572
Chief Kwenkeze and kill him there."
cue-1573
They all agreed. As they went on, some old
acquaintances came by, mocking him. He
cue-1574
begged one for a piece of cloth.
cue-1575
-"Not me,"
-The man sneered.
cue-1576
-"I'm going to buy you."
-When they reached another stream, Matula
cue-1577
couldn't go any farther.
cue-1578
He lay down and begged through tears.
cue-1579
"Kill me, for the angels are waiting to
carry my spirit to heaven."
cue-1580
This only made them more furious. They
beat him with sticks and ropes.
cue-1581
-"Have mercy. Kill me with a gani,"
-He pleaded.
cue-1582
But they had no such mercy in mind. Like a
cat playing with a mouse, they
cue-1583
dragged him further along a rough path.
Blood seeped from his wounds, but these
cue-1584
cruel men showed no pity.
cue-1585
When they reached the next village, they
summoned a man who had been secretly
cue-1586
assigned to kill Matula. He came forward,
sharpening a large knife.
cue-1587
He reached out his hand to Matula and gave
him a kiembote,
cue-1588
a farewell.
cue-1589
Then, with cold determination, he raised
the knife high to strike.But just before
cue-1590
he could bring it down, someone stopped
him, saying, "Chief Kwenkesi is not here,
cue-1591
and he must be present."
cue-1592
More discussion followed. They then took
Matula on to Kwenkesi's place. The
cue-1593
chief was surprised to see them so late,
for the sun had long since set. He
cue-1594
welcomed them with a feast, though Matula
could barely eat.
cue-1595
That night, they bound him inside a house.
He was laid on his back, arms and
cue-1596
legs stretched out and tied to opposite
walls.
cue-1597
Ropes around his waist were connected to
guards on either side, and the forked
cue-1598
stick around his neck was fastened to the
low roof beam.
cue-1599
In his misery, Matula prayed to God,
asking for help, for a quick death
cue-1600
or for deliverance in some other way.
cue-1601
It was a long and sleepless night,
cue-1602
but at last, the dawn came.
cue-1603
No help arrived,
cue-1604
yet his faith in God did not waver.
cue-1605
Soon, a messenger came from Makuta,
warning them that word had spread.
cue-1606
If the state found out, there would be
consequences.
cue-1607
Though they ignored the warning, they did
slightly loosen the bindings on his legs
cue-1608
and relaxed the ropes a bit.
cue-1609
Then they led him to the village where the
judgment or palaver was to take place.
cue-1610
There, Matula begged the chief for a piece
of cloth.
cue-1611
The chief, moved perhaps by a trace of
mercy, tore his own cloth in two
cue-1612
and gave him half.
cue-1613
Matula again pleaded with them, warning of
the evil they were committing and saying
cue-1614
that if they killed him, they would face
punishment, if not now,
cue-1615
then eventually.
cue-1616
But his words had no effect.
cue-1617
That night, they tied him again just as
before.
cue-1618
In the morning, a large gathering was
held.
cue-1619
The old accusations of witchcraft were
raised once more. He had associated with
cue-1620
the missionary, given him a boy, and had
taken his people to Ngombe, where they
cue-1621
were starting to follow God and this new
teaching.
cue-1622
It was enough evidence, they said.
cue-1623
He must be a witch, and witches, of
course, must be killed.
cue-1624
The chief presiding over the council
called for a vote.
cue-1625
Every vote was cast against Matula.
cue-1626
They agreed to send for an executioner to
carry out the sentence the next day,
cue-1627
and Matula's body was to be thrown into
the river Kwilu. Not a single voice, not
cue-1628
even a faint one, spoke in his defense.
cue-1629
That evening, some women noticed a
stranger in the woods preparing long
cue-1630
cords, and they wondered at his actions.
He was the hired killer, getting
cue-1631
ready to tie Matula securely for the night
to ensure he would not escape before
cue-1632
morning. That night, Matula was bound
again,
cue-1633
his feet tied to heavy iron clogs, his
arms fastened together beneath his head,
cue-1634
the forked stick once more attached to the
low ridge pole, and his waist secured to
cue-1635
guards on either side. He was surrounded
by six guards. To his left
cue-1636
lay the murderer, well paid to carry out
the execution. To the native mind,
cue-1637
everything had been done according to
custom. There was no chance of escape.
cue-1638
Believing this to be the final night of
his life, Matula cried out to God, though
cue-1639
with little hope.
cue-1640
Unless a miracle happened, he would die in
the morning.
cue-1641
Chapter Thirteen:
cue-1642
Escape.
cue-1643
In September 1897, I was traveling to
Tumba to visit Mr. and Mrs. Graham,
cue-1644
who had come from San Salvador to
temporarily replace Mr. Popple.
cue-1645
As we neared Tumba, we saw Matula's two
companions running toward us in great
cue-1646
haste. Their faces showed alarm, and
before we could speak, they cried out,
cue-1647
"Matula is murdered," with tears in their
eyes.
cue-1648
"Surely not," I said.
cue-1649
"There must be some mistake."
cue-1650
"No, no," they insisted. "We saw him
beaten and stabbed with a knife. There is
cue-1651
no mistake."
cue-1652
"All right," I said. "Mr. Bentley has
returned. Go and tell him quickly."
cue-1653
We needed to report to the state
authorities, for we were responsible for
cue-1654
ensuring Matula would appear at Tumba if
summoned. The two men ran off without
cue-1655
waiting to hear more, and we continued our
journey, heavy-hearted. None of the
cue-1656
boys with us could speak a word.
cue-1657
We had all grown to love Matula. His calm,
gentle spirit was so
cue-1658
different from most others.
cue-1659
When we arrived at Tumba, it was the first
thing we talked about.
cue-1660
The two men had also spoken with Mr.
Graham. He and Mrs. Graham were as grieved
cue-1661
as I was.
cue-1662
Though they had only met Matula a few
times, they had been deeply impressed by
cue-1663
him
cue-1664
and surprised to learn he had not yet been
received into church fellowship.
cue-1665
A day or two later, a letter arrived from
Mr. Bentley, addressed to the
cue-1666
commissioner, and Mr. Graham was preparing
to deliver it.
cue-1667
Just then, astonishing news came.
cue-1668
Matula had escaped. We questioned the boy
who brought the report, but he had only
cue-1669
heard it from some travelers coming from
the Makuta area.
cue-1670
At first, we found it hard to believe. It
sounded too miraculous, especially in our
cue-1671
skeptical times when people say the age of
miracles is over.
cue-1672
Soon after, we met some of the men who had
tied Matula up, though we didn't realize
cue-1673
it at the time, and Mr. Graham questioned
them closely.
cue-1674
We still feared the escape story was a
cover-up for murder, but our doubts didn't
cue-1675
last long.
cue-1676
Within an hour or two, Ponde arrived. He
confirmed the news, saying he had seen
cue-1677
Matula himself after he escaped and that
he had come straight to Makuta.
cue-1678
Matula was too weak to travel far, so
Ponde had left him behind to rest.
cue-1679
I had to leave that day with my small
caravan,
cue-1680
but our hearts were overflowing with
gratitude to God for sparing Matula's life
cue-1681
and showing his power.
cue-1682
We spent another ten days on the road,
visiting villages in my district about 40
cue-1683
miles east of Tumba, and then returned to
Ngombe.
cue-1684
My colleagues were expecting Matula's
arrival at any moment, and many of his
cue-1685
people had gone out to meet him at
Kimpete.
cue-1686
A few days later, they returned,
cue-1687
Matula leading them, accompanied by Mr.
and Mrs. Graham, who were visiting
cue-1688
Ngombe.Poor man. He looked utterly
exhausted.
cue-1689
He said he had delayed coming because he
was ashamed for us to see how thin he had
cue-1690
become.
cue-1691
His people were overcome with joy, and the
boys and girls at the station could not
cue-1692
have been more thrilled if he had been a
white man.
cue-1693
Later, he gave us a detailed account of
his capture and being dragged from town to
cue-1694
town over two days and nights. The story
you've already read. That's where we
cue-1695
left him on the third night,
cue-1696
bound hand and foot, awaiting the morning
with no hope of rescue,
cue-1697
sure that his death was near.
cue-1698
With no help left on earth, Matula
committed himself to God's care.
cue-1699
He prayed for deliverance if it was God's
will or else for restful sleep.
cue-1700
All six guards had fallen asleep, and
Matula himself began to drift off
cue-1701
until he woke with a strange feeling in
his feet.
cue-1702
What was it? They were burning.
cue-1703
Then he realized the truth. His feet had
been bound over the ashes of the fire from
cue-1704
the night before. Fires in the Congo,
like the ancient Druid fires, are
cue-1705
rarely fully extinguished. With a bit of
dry grass and a breeze, a flame can be
cue-1706
rekindled at any time.
cue-1707
Rope made from fibrous materials will
slowly smolder and eventually break.
cue-1708
That's what happened to the cords binding
Matula's feet. They smoldered and burned
cue-1709
through.
cue-1710
What freedom he felt.
cue-1711
Though his waist, hands, and neck were
still tied, the ability to move his feet
cue-1712
gave him leverage.
cue-1713
Slowly, he worked his hands forward. The
cord slipped off the forked stick.
cue-1714
He brought his hands in front of him and
managed to free them.
cue-1715
Still, he had to move carefully. His
guards were stirring.
cue-1716
Were they awake?
cue-1717
He tested them by calling out, asking to
be tied again.
cue-1718
They made no reply. Whether they were
asleep or too afraid to move,
cue-1719
he didn't know.
cue-1720
Quietly, he wriggled out of the cords
around his waist.
cue-1721
Now only the iron clogs on his feet
remained. He crept to the door and slipped
cue-1722
outside into the cool night air.
cue-1723
It was refreshing.
cue-1724
Looking around for tools, he found a
hatchet and a large knife and used them to
cue-1725
break free from the irons. Then he ran,
cue-1726
any direction, just to get away from that
place. He tried to find the road to Tumba,
cue-1727
but disoriented and unsure of his
location, he couldn't tell which way to
cue-1728
go.
cue-1729
He followed the first visible path, which
led to a cassava garden. Fires
cue-1730
burned and voices could be heard. Natives
were out guarding the fields from
cue-1731
elephants.
cue-1732
He skirted the area to avoid being
spotted.
cue-1733
Ahead, he came upon an elephant track and
saw a mother elephant with her calf. He
cue-1734
knew he couldn't risk going that way.
cue-1735
He quickly turned aside and found a narrow
path that led him to the Kwilu River.
cue-1736
As he stood on the bank, he heard the
ominous sounds of crocodiles below. He
cue-1737
remembered how many people had been killed
by them.
cue-1738
Terrified, he turned back.
cue-1739
What could he do?
cue-1740
Returning meant recapture.
cue-1741
Going along the elephant path meant facing
wild beasts.
cue-1742
Entering the river meant risking the
crocodiles.
cue-1743
Staying in place could bring a buffalo
attack.
cue-1744
Every option seemed deadly.
cue-1745
In desperation, Matula prayed earnestly,
asking God, who had just
cue-1746
delivered him from his enemies, to now
guide his next step.
cue-1747
As he prayed, peace came.
cue-1748
He felt God's answer.
cue-1749
It is better to fall into the hands of God
than into those of wicked men.
cue-1750
Beasts obey their creator. They are less
dangerous than evil men.
cue-1751
With renewed faith, he stepped into the
river and swam safely to the other side.
cue-1752
The water revived him.
cue-1753
He paused to wash away the clotted blood
that covered his body.
cue-1754
As he did, an antelope and its young came
and looked at him, leaving and returning
cue-1755
several times.
cue-1756
It was as if God had sent this gentle
creature as a sign of peace and
cue-1757
reassurance.
cue-1758
He climbed up the far bank of the river.
cue-1759
Now more aware of his surroundings, he
carefully continued on, avoiding every
cue-1760
village.
cue-1761
As dawn approached, he had to be even more
cautious.
cue-1762
Whenever travelers came near, Matula would
hide in the tall grass.
cue-1763
He asked several people the way to Makuta,
cue-1764
but they were too frightened to answer
him. As the morning progressed, more
cue-1765
travelers appeared, all heading to the
district's large market.
cue-1766
Matula saw a group approaching and hid in
the woods.
cue-1767
Peering through the branches, he
recognized two of Ponde's boys leading a
cue-1768
goat. When he called to them, they were
startled, having heard he was dead.
cue-1769
But they stopped and listened as he
explained and then told him Ponde was at
cue-1770
home.
cue-1771
Encouraged, Matula hurried to Makuta and
headed straight for the prayer house,
cue-1772
expecting to find Ponde there. He opened
the door and called out,
cue-1773
"Ponde.
cue-1774
Friend.
cue-1775
Ponde."
cue-1776
But a small boy, terrified, rushed out,
crying, "Matula's ghost has come."
cue-1777
Ponde came quickly to see for himself,
cue-1778
and to his joy and amazement, there stood
Matula, alive.
cue-1779
The two embraced out of sheer joy,
cue-1780
something very uncommon among the Congo
people.
cue-1781
Hot water and medicine were quickly
brought, and his many wounds were washed
cue-1782
and dressed.
cue-1783
Then,
cue-1784
relieved and safe with a friend, Matula
lay down on a mat and soon fell
cue-1785
into a deep, peaceful sleep.
cue-1786
He remained indoors for several days,
lovingly cared for by Ponde as tenderly as
cue-1787
a mother would nurse her own child.
cue-1788
Word soon spread that Matula had escaped,
cue-1789
but his pursuers were too afraid to try
capturing him again.
cue-1790
They assumed the state would finish the
job they had failed to carry out.
cue-1791
Matula also anticipated the upcoming
trial, but this time with more hope and
cue-1792
confidence, for he had experienced a clear
sign of God's power and protection.
cue-1793
Chapter 14: Trial at TumbaNot long after
Matula
cue-1794
returned to Ngombe, Mr. Graham wrote to
Mr. Cameron, Mr. Bentley having gone back
cue-1795
to England, asking that Matula be sent to
Tumba to appear before the judge, expected
cue-1796
in three or four days.
cue-1797
In his letter, Mr. Graham also requested
earnest prayer for Matula. His
cue-1798
enemies had carefully prepared their
accusations, while Matula, because of the
cue-1799
nature of the charges, had no witnesses,
cue-1800
only those who could testify to his gentle
character.
cue-1801
The commissioner said the case looked bad,
and unless Matula could prove his
cue-1802
innocence, he would certainly be hanged as
a warning to others.
cue-1803
Still, Matula went fearlessly to Tumba,
confident in his innocence.
cue-1804
Though he saw no path forward, he trusted
God was with him.
cue-1805
At Ngombe, we lifted him up daily in
prayer, asking our wise and loving Father
cue-1806
to defend the innocent,
cue-1807
for we were convinced Matula was indeed
innocent. When Matula arrived at
cue-1808
Tumba, he was shocked to find some of his
former accusers in chains.
cue-1809
The government had learned about their
attempt to murder him and had sent a
cue-1810
sergeant and soldiers to arrest them.
cue-1811
The troops arrived in Mongo just as the
people were gathering for the burial of
cue-1812
the chief's mother, who had remained
unburied for months.
cue-1813
Several pigs had been slaughtered for the
occasion and many cloths collected. The
cue-1814
soldiers seized these and took the accused
men to Tumba. Even in custody, they
cue-1815
repeated the same accusation against
Matula, claiming they had only tied him up
cue-1816
to ensure his appearance in court.
cue-1817
In truth, they were terrified,
cue-1818
especially since Matula had warned them
that punishment would come.
cue-1819
The details of what followed in Tumba were
best told by Meister Graham of San
cue-1820
Salvador, who witnessed the trial
firsthand. He explained that the delay in
cue-1821
Matula's trial had been so long it seemed
the government had forgotten the case,
cue-1822
likely due to illness and changes in
judges.
cue-1823
The arrest of Matula's would-be murderer
may have revived interest in the matter.
cue-1824
Soon afterward, Mr. Graham was notified
that the trial would be held on December
cue-1825
ninth.
cue-1826
Matula was brought to Tumba on December
eighth to await the hearing.
cue-1827
But the judge failed to arrive. Again,
they were told the judge was coming, and
cue-1828
again they brought Matula and his
witnesses,
cue-1829
but the judge was sick, and the case was
postponed a second time on December
cue-1830
sixteenth.
cue-1831
On the following day, December
seventeenth, Mr. Graham wrote to the judge
cue-1832
explaining that they had twice
transported Matula and his witnesses only
cue-1833
to return again and asking who would be
appointed as Matula's defense and when
cue-1834
they should come back once more. On
Sunday, December nineteenth, I received a
cue-1835
wire from the judge stating that Monsieur
L had been appointed Matula's defender and
cue-1836
the trial would take place on Thursday.
cue-1837
On Monday, I met with M. L and explained
the entire case to him. Then I reviewed
cue-1838
the notes from the earlier trial and
discovered that the translator had
cue-1839
completely misrepresented the facts.
cue-1840
After reading the supposed evidence
presented to the judge, M. L believed that
cue-1841
guilty or not, Matula would be hanged.
cue-1842
I too feared that unless the Lord
intervened, this would end in judicial
cue-1843
murder.
cue-1844
Needless to say, I slept little until the
trial concluded.
cue-1845
That same day, by what seemed divine
providence, I found two witnesses who had
cue-1846
been with Matula at another location
during the time of the alleged murder.
cue-1847
I almost forced them to stay and testify
cue-1848
in case the key witnesses failed to
arrive,
cue-1849
and it was well I did.
cue-1850
Meanwhile, we interviewed every possible
witness and sent for others.
cue-1851
The most crucial of these was a woman who
had cared for her sister,
cue-1852
one of the two women Matula was accused of
killing. Both had died of smallpox, and
cue-1853
this had occurred years before the
supposed attack.
cue-1854
On Wednesday afternoon, the judge and the
prosecuting attorney arrived from Matadi
cue-1855
by train.
cue-1856
Unfortunately, the most vital witnesses
were delayed by a storm and didn't arrive
cue-1857
until after the trial had ended the next
day.
cue-1858
Then came the morning on which Matula's
fate was to be decided.
cue-1859
By mid-morning, people had gathered
outside the plain-looking grass building
cue-1860
marked with the grand title, Tumba Palais
de Justice.
cue-1861
Soon, the judge, prosecuting attorney,
clerk, defense counsel, interpreter,
cue-1862
prisoner, soldiers, witnesses, and Mr.
Graham were seen arriving from different
cue-1863
directions and filing into the courtroom.
Mr. Graham brought up the
cue-1864
rear, carefully scanning the area to see
if any expected witnesses had arrived.
cue-1865
Guards took their positions outside the
door.
cue-1866
The natives stood in silent awe at the
solemn formality with which the judge and
cue-1867
counsel took their seats and prepared for
the day's proceedings.
cue-1868
Everything at the Tumba trial was carried
out as far as possible with the formality
cue-1869
and dignity of a European court, much like
it would be in Brussels. The
cue-1870
contrast with native justice was extreme.
In traditional native courts, proceedings
cue-1871
are typically held in the open air.
cue-1872
The highest-ranking chief sits on the
ground atop a leopard skin, sometimes
cue-1873
draped in a cloth,
cue-1874
holding a spear or having it nearby.
cue-1875
Other chiefs sit squatting around him, all
trying to look as important as possible.
cue-1876
Such native trials often begin with
offerings of malavu,
cue-1877
palm wine, and heavy bribes, and cases are
frequently postponed due to
cue-1878
confusion, argument, and chaos between the
parties involved.
cue-1879
So imagine the awe of those used to that
system when they entered a formal
cue-1880
courtroom. State officials in dark robes
and white collars, solemn-faced,
cue-1881
questioning and cross-questioning.
cue-1882
It's no wonder native witnesses quaked,
stumbled, and gave confused answers,
cue-1883
just as some had during Matula's earlier
hearing. Returning to Mr. Graham's
cue-1884
account, he explained that he attended the
trial only as a visitor, though in
cue-1885
practice he served as an informal legal
advisor to Monsieur L, Matula's appointed
cue-1886
defender.
cue-1887
A major setback was the absence of key
witnesses.
cue-1888
However, witnesses from the opposing side
also failed to appear, balancing things
cue-1889
somewhat.Mr. Graham had emphasized several
key points to Monsieur L
cue-1890
in Matula's defense.
cue-1891
A woman from Matente, not Matembe, no such
place exists, had been captured
cue-1892
years earlier by Yalala, a friend of
Matula's family, in revenge for Matente
cue-1893
capturing his son. This woman, Kinziona,
was sold to Kuba of
cue-1894
Kwilu and later died there of smallpox
along with another woman. The sister of
cue-1895
one of the women had nursed them both to
the end. This caregiver and others who
cue-1896
knew the case were on their way to
testify.
cue-1897
This incident, including the capture and
death of Kinziona, clearly occurred long
cue-1898
before late 1896, before the Congo Railway
arrived and before the state's
cue-1899
law extended over the area.
cue-1900
Therefore, any actions involved were part
of a native conflict and could not be
cue-1901
judged under laws that had not yet been
established.
cue-1902
As for Matula, he was well known to
Reverend W.H. Bentley and other
cue-1903
missionaries, both before and after the
supposed murder.
cue-1904
All gave a strong testimony of his good
character.
cue-1905
Moreover, despite their knowledge of the
region, none of the missionaries had heard
cue-1906
any rumor or report of such a murder
around the time in question.
cue-1907
Matula firmly denied ever visiting Matente
and denied ever killing
cue-1908
anyone or striking any woman as the
charges claimed.
cue-1909
The clearest evidence showed he had no
part in the quarrel during which Kinziona
cue-1910
was captured by Yalala's group.
cue-1911
At that time, Matula had been away trading
in another area and only heard of the
cue-1912
conflict upon his return.
cue-1913
Two witnesses confirmed this.
cue-1914
A man who gave evidence against Matula
under the name Weo, better known as
cue-1915
Kwenkezi, was not Weo at all, but Masamba,
either his son or slave,
cue-1916
who falsely claimed to be Weo.
cue-1917
The real Weo, afraid his lie would be
exposed, did not appear at the trial.
cue-1918
In contrast, Matula, though he could
easily have avoided trial, chose to appear
cue-1919
three separate times, each with great
inconvenience to himself and his family.
cue-1920
Moreover, Mafuku, Weo's nephew and heir,
along with others, had recently
cue-1921
attempted to murder Matula.
cue-1922
Mafuku was now in prison on that charge.
cue-1923
Clearly, it was not Matula, but his
enemies who had broken the law and acted
cue-1924
against the state.
cue-1925
Matula's defense counsel took these facts
and presented a powerful speech.
cue-1926
He convinced both the judge and the
prosecuting attorney so thoroughly that
cue-1927
they chose to hear Matula's own testimony.
cue-1928
Matula spoke with clarity, calm, and
integrity.
cue-1929
In his closing remarks, the judge stated
that there had been much false testimony
cue-1930
against the accused and rejoiced that the
weight of evidence clearly supported
cue-1931
Matula's innocence. He then dismissed the
case and declared Matula free with a clean
cue-1932
record.
cue-1933
Upon leaving the courtroom, Mr. Graham and
the others met the delayed witnesses,
cue-1934
too late to testify.
cue-1935
The prosecuting attorney sternly rebuked
Masamba and Diamoni, Weo's wife.
cue-1936
And when his knowledge of the language
failed, Mr. Graham took over. They both
cue-1937
made sure the false witnesses understood
the gravity of their actions, and they
cue-1938
likely won't risk perjury again. When
Matula reunited with his friends, who
cue-1939
arrived in style as if they owned the
street, he told them.
cue-1940
Yes, I am free, but no thanks to you. If I
had trusted in you instead
cue-1941
-of God, I might have been hanged.
-The trial for Mafuku and the others who
cue-1942
had tried to kill Matula was brief. They
had been imprisoned for months, and Matula
cue-1943
did not want harsh punishment. After a
stern warning and being bound over to
cue-1944
keep the peace, they were released. Once
everything was settled at Tumba, Matula
cue-1945
wasted no time returning home.
cue-1946
That day of his return to the station was
unforgettable. As word spread, crowds
cue-1947
rushed out to meet him. Guns were fired in
celebration, and the people danced with
cue-1948
joy.
cue-1949
At the Thanksgiving service, emotion ran
high.
cue-1950
Tears of joy filled many eyes as everyone
recognized that God had truly
cue-1951
heard and answered prayer.
cue-1952
Matula has often returned to his old town,
sincerely wanting to show his relatives
cue-1953
that he had truly forgiven them.
cue-1954
His trials had shaped him into a man full
of love and gentleness.
cue-1955
He became known as a true gentleman, one
of the most genuine and sincere men in
cue-1956
all Congo.
cue-1957
Mr. Pinnock once said of him,
cue-1958
"He is the only one-eyed fellow I know in
Congo," meaning he lived with a single
cue-1959
focus to glorify God in all things.
cue-1960
Chapter 15: Days of Peace.
cue-1961
In 1899, Matula was received into church
fellowship. His life was
cue-1962
above reproach, and his simple, unwavering
faith in the Lord Jesus made it
cue-1963
impossible to withhold communion from him.
cue-1964
Because the African people are so
impressionable, leaders must be cautious
cue-1965
about publicly recognizing new disciples.
cue-1966
But Matula had already passed through a
long season of trial and suffering and had
cue-1967
remained faithful, even to the brink of
death, for the sake of Christ.
cue-1968
Not long after his baptism, his remaining
wife, Kento, was also baptized after
cue-1969
professing her faith in Christ.
cue-1970
She had been a faithful support to him in
all his hardships, and through it all, her
cue-1971
faith had never wavered.
cue-1972
She was his first wife, married in 1889
when she was about sixteen years old.
cue-1973
According to native custom, he had taken
two other wives but never felt deeply
cue-1974
attached to them.
cue-1975
One abandoned him during the persecution.
The other died shortly after they arrived
cue-1976
at Ngombe. She had been happy with Matula,
for even by native standards, he had
cue-1977
always been a kind and considerate
husband.
cue-1978
Yet one cannot help feeling her passing
was merciful, for the heart of a man
cue-1979
always cleaves to his first love.
cue-1980
For years, they had passed through
troubled waters, often close to despair.
cue-1981
But now the Lord had brought them into a
peaceful harbor.Every visitor
cue-1982
to their home felt it,
cue-1983
peace and quietness.
cue-1984
Their neat houses, tidy fences, clean
paths, and well-kept gardens all
cue-1985
reflected a home where it was a joy to
live.
cue-1986
In the mornings, the sound of the pestle
pounding dried cassava into flour, the
cue-1987
clucking of hens, and the bleating of
goats spoke of a rare industriousness
cue-1988
worth noting in the Congo.
cue-1989
And in the evening, in a culture where men
often feel ashamed to even acknowledge
cue-1990
their wives in public, this warm,
contented couple could be seen walking
cue-1991
together around Vianga, Vianga or entering
the missionary's house side by side.
cue-1992
Wherever we met them, there was always a
cheerful smile, a kind greeting, and a
cue-1993
native courtesy that was a delight to
witness.
cue-1994
I often wondered if they had some noble
blood in their veins,
cue-1995
for their expressions and behavior were so
unlike the average Congolese.
cue-1996
In Lower Congo, there are indeed a number
of natives with refined manners, graceful
cue-1997
movements, and delicate features, making
one wonder if they are descendants of a
cue-1998
nobler lineage than most.
cue-1999
But that, of course, remains speculation.
cue-2000
Matula was richly blessed after coming to
live among the believers at Ngombe. He and
cue-2001
his wife attended school faithfully and
soon learned to read and write quite well.
cue-2002
Matula found great comfort in reading his
Ekangu Diampha
cue-2003
Bible and had the joy of seeing more than
twelve members of his household received
cue-2004
into church fellowship.
cue-2005
Two of his sisters married native
evangelists and were blessed with
cue-2006
children.
cue-2007
One particular joy and weight of
responsibility was their only surviving
cue-2008
child, a bright ten-year-old girl.
cue-2009
Matula also had a son, but it was this
little girl who was their constant
cue-2010
delight and concern.
cue-2011
Above all, Matula rejoiced most in the
great transformation that came over his
cue-2012
home village of Mongo.
cue-2013
In early eighteen ninety-nine, Mr. Cameron
visited the district and, to his
cue-2014
surprise and joy, found the people asking
for a teacher to show them the way to God.
cue-2015
The old chief had died and was succeeded
by a young man named Lunenga, who was
cue-2016
eager to learn and follow God, just as the
people of Makuta had done for years.
cue-2017
Lunenga had not been present during
Matula's persecution, but when he heard
cue-2018
about it, he was deeply ashamed.
cue-2019
From then on, he became one of Matula's
truest friends.
cue-2020
A capable and earnest teacher was sent to
Mongo, and soon a prayer house was built
cue-2021
and later expanded.
cue-2022
Around sixty to seventy students attended
regularly, and Lunenga himself, along with
cue-2023
several others, was baptized.
cue-2024
In nineteen hundred, Lunenga accompanied
the missionary to a neighboring town where
cue-2025
he had lived during Matula's time of
suffering.
cue-2026
Because of his earlier heartfelt appeals
and strong witness for the truth, the
cue-2027
people there were now eager to receive a
teacher as well.
cue-2028
A young man was left to teach them, and
the people enthusiastically built a fine
cue-2029
house of worship, which was soon filled
for daily prayers.
cue-2030
Nearly seventy students enrolled in the
school, and many began to seek God
cue-2031
earnestly.
cue-2032
From both Mongo and this new town,
Kinsende, there is hope that the spiritual
cue-2033
fire will spread to many more towns,
cue-2034
fires kindled by the flames of persecution
once directed at the innocent and
cue-2035
faithful Matula.
cue-2036
Chapter sixteen: Signs of Coming Trouble.
cue-2037
In nineteen hundred, many were sick with
chest and throat infections, and Matula
cue-2038
was among them.
cue-2039
One night, I was woken by Nlemvo, who told
me Matula was very ill and feared he
cue-2040
might be dying.
cue-2041
I quickly dressed and went to his home.
cue-2042
The room was quiet when I arrived.
cue-2043
Matula was breathing fast, and his face
looked anxious and troubled. At first, I
cue-2044
thought he was near death.
cue-2045
As we stood watching, to our surprise, he
began singing softly. "Follow, follow,
cue-2046
I will follow Jesus."
cue-2047
Then confused, he murmured,
cue-2048
"Oh, kill me now. Kill me now with a gun.
cue-2049
I want to be free. The angels are waiting
for me."
cue-2050
It seemed he was reliving his past
suffering.
cue-2051
Later, he awoke and gently told his wife,
who hadn't slept in two nights, not to
cue-2052
cry, but to try to rest.
cue-2053
"Don't cry.
cue-2054
If I die,
cue-2055
I am going to heaven, and you will soon
follow me."
cue-2056
Then turning to others nearby, he said,
"If I go, your father will be gone,
cue-2057
but don't weep for me.
cue-2058
Stay here and continue your work.
cue-2059
You young women only marry Christians and
go where they go."
cue-2060
His words came slowly.
cue-2061
He was very weak.
cue-2062
His cough was severe, and at times he
seemed like he would choke.
cue-2063
I stayed at his bedside for two hours,
giving him soothing medicine, but I truly
cue-2064
didn't think he would recover. He remained
in this condition for two or three days.
cue-2065
We fought hard, and by God's grace, he
pulled through, though I always sensed he
cue-2066
was disappointed as he had wanted to go
home to God.
cue-2067
His recovery was slow and took nearly six
weeks.
cue-2068
Even after that, he never regained his old
strength, and I began to worry that he
cue-2069
wouldn't be with us much longer.
cue-2070
Some of those who came with him had
returned to Mongo after the teacher left,
cue-2071
while others were taken by the dreadful
disease, sleeping sickness.
cue-2072
Before Matula became ill, Mankwenia,
cue-2073
the boy he had first given to Mr. Bentley,
died from it,
cue-2074
and the two companions who had traveled
with him on that unforgettable journey
cue-2075
also became victims.
cue-2076
His mother had died not long after his
return from Tumba.
cue-2077
These losses weighed heavily on him.
cue-2078
Sleeping sickness is a terrible,
heartbreaking disease.
cue-2079
Thousands die from it every year in Congo.
It is sweeping through the land at a
cue-2080
frightening pace, and yet no one knows how
to stop it.
cue-2081
The illness has been studied in medical
journals and in London hospitals,
cue-2082
but no solution has been found.
cue-2083
It is heartbreaking to hear of faithful
Christian believers suddenly being struck
cue-2084
down by it.The thought that Matula might
now have it is too painful. Oh,
cue-2085
that someone skilled and compassionate
would hear the cry of these suffering
cue-2086
people and come to help.
cue-2087
Even if such a mission brought little
fame, the reward would be immense. To
cue-2088
discover the cause of these countless
deaths and to stop this dreadful disease
cue-2089
would be a work worthy of the brightest
minds. But this must be studied among the
cue-2090
victims themselves, where the disease is
doing its damage.
cue-2091
One Sunday, Matula came to me wrapped in
an old blanket, looking weak and unlike
cue-2092
himself.
cue-2093
'What's wrong?'
cue-2094
I asked.
cue-2095
-'I came to talk to you about myself,'
-he replied.
cue-2096
'You white men are my friends.
cue-2097
I want you to tell me honestly, do I have
sleeping sickness?
cue-2098
I've heard people talking. I think
Christians shouldn't hide things. I'd
cue-2099
rather know so I can prepare myself. I
feel pain in my legs, and I don't sleep
cue-2100
well at night. I only half doze and dream.
cue-2101
Last night,
cue-2102
I had a dream, not something I heard or
read, but I thought we're like trees in
cue-2103
the forest.
cue-2104
They grow up toward heaven. They may get
trimmed,
cue-2105
but they keep growing until someone cuts
them down to plant something else.
cue-2106
Then their roots wither, and their
branches are burned.
cue-2107
We're like that.
cue-2108
We grow and thrive,
cue-2109
suffer for a while,
cue-2110
then go on until God cuts down the ones
who aren't useful to plant others.'
cue-2111
He kept talking, and I thanked God for
this one precious life transformed by the
cue-2112
-gospel.
-'I also dreamed of water,'
cue-2113
-he continued.
-'It flowed gently, sometimes loudly over
cue-2114
rocks, saying, 'I cannot stay.
cue-2115
I must go on.'
cue-2116
But as it passed, someone could drink and
be refreshed.
cue-2117
I think I'm like that, passing quickly.
cue-2118
Maybe God used me like the water to bless
someone. I'm not afraid to go into
cue-2119
glory. But if I die,
cue-2120
what will happen to my roots,
cue-2121
my wife, and children?'
cue-2122
He became quiet,
cue-2123
and I sensed he had more to say.
cue-2124
'Now, when I go to school, the children
laugh at me because I'm slow.
cue-2125
I feel some pride rise in me against the
teacher,
cue-2126
Sue, who's just a boy.
cue-2127
But I ask God to forgive me. I try hard,
but sometimes I spend a whole hour on one
cue-2128
sum.
cue-2129
They think I don't want to learn, but it's
not true.
cue-2130
Sometimes the devil tells me not to go
back, but I pray for strength and go
cue-2131
because I know it pleases Jesus.
cue-2132
Still,
cue-2133
I feel weaker.'
cue-2134
Poor Matula. The fear of sleeping sickness
seemed to haunt him, which was itself a
cue-2135
sign.
cue-2136
I told him we couldn't be certain yet, but
reminded him how God had cared for him
cue-2137
before. Just as his enemies couldn't kill
him, neither could this disease if it
cue-2138
wasn't God's will.
cue-2139
We would pray earnestly for him.
cue-2140
I reminded him that God blesses the one
who delights to do his will, like a tree
cue-2141
planted by streams of water.
cue-2142
Our bodies, though, are like grass or
trees that are cut down.
cue-2143
-'Is that in the Bible?'
-he asked.
cue-2144
I turned to 1 Peter and read the last
verses of chapter 1.
cue-2145
He asked to see it, so I read from verse
13 to the end. He was delighted
cue-2146
by the truth that we were bought not with
perishable things, but with the precious
cue-2147
blood of Christ.
cue-2148
I had to read the whole chapter to satisfy
him.
cue-2149
It was a revelation to him that his
sufferings had been a test of faith
cue-2150
allowed by God. He had thought it was only
the devil's doing. His face lit
cue-2151
up with joy as he realized God had been
guiding him through it all.
cue-2152
Like Job, he had suffered much, but the
devil could not take his life.
cue-2153
Matula now saw all his trials as small
things in light of what he now knew of
cue-2154
God's love, power, and goodness.
cue-2155
It was a joyful morning.
cue-2156
The gloom he brought with him disappeared,
and he left beaming with peace.
cue-2157
He returned to live quietly in his home,
near his wife's, burdened by what we
cue-2158
feared was an incurable and contagious
illness.
cue-2159
He was extremely careful not to infect his
wife or children.
cue-2160
At communion, it was touching to see him
use his own glass for wine and ask his
cue-2161
neighbor to place a piece of bread before
him, afraid even to touch the plate and
cue-2162
risk contaminating it.
cue-2163
Simple, sincere-hearted Matula.
cue-2164
There are sadly too few like him.
cue-2165
Chapter 17. Matula's Last Days.
cue-2166
After the earlier chapters were written, I
was overjoyed to read that a medical
cue-2167
commission had been sent to Uganda to
investigate the cause of the dreadful
cue-2168
sleep sickness.
cue-2169
May God grant success to their work so
that thousands of lives may be saved and
cue-2170
brighter days come to Central Africa.
cue-2171
To our deep sorrow, Matula became one of
the victims of this terrible disease.
cue-2172
Sleep sickness affects people differently.
In those who are naturally slow and
cue-2173
quiet, it dulls every sense like a strong
sedative, leaving them
cue-2174
dazed and half-conscious.
cue-2175
In the active and lively, it fights hard
to take over, like a strong man trying to
cue-2176
overpower another. They resist and fight,
cue-2177
but gradually, as the mind weakens, their
efforts become wild and irrational.
cue-2178
Fits of temper, bursts of madness, and
unreasonable behavior in otherwise gentle
cue-2179
people are almost always early signs of
the disease, showing the mind's attempt to
cue-2180
resist.
cue-2181
These strong-willed patients usually take
longer to be overcome, especially if they
cue-2182
are well cared for in the early stages.
cue-2183
The illness can seem to lie hidden for a
time, then suddenly show itself through a
cue-2184
storm of emotion or madness.This was how
it happened with Matula.
cue-2185
For many months, we suspected he had the
disease, though it remained hidden.
cue-2186
His faithful wife, Kento, cared for him
with love and gentleness. But many of his
cue-2187
dear friends and family died, and others
longed to return to their home at Mongo,
cue-2188
now a place of peace.
cue-2189
They left reluctantly, and Matula was left
with only his wife, a sister, and three
cue-2190
young children.
cue-2191
This loneliness, combined with the effects
of the illness on his mind, caused him to
cue-2192
turn on his wife, accusing her of being
the cause of his pain, and he began to
cue-2193
beat her. Then he would break down,
weeping, full of guilt and sorrow.
cue-2194
Eventually, he became too violent to be
kept at home safely.
cue-2195
Fearing for his wife's safety, we
suggested restraining him.
cue-2196
But as soon as he heard the word chain, he
ran off without a word.
cue-2197
Later, we learned he had returned to his
old home, traveling day and night.
cue-2198
Soon after, his wife and sister followed
to care for him there.
cue-2199
He lived only about two more months.
cue-2200
During most of that time, he was not in
his right mind.
cue-2201
But in moments of clarity, it was clear
his heart still trusted the one in whom he
cue-2202
had believed for so many years.
cue-2203
Kento herself shared the account of
Matula's final days.
cue-2204
News of his illness and episodes of
madness had reached Mongo before he
cue-2205
arrived. The people expected outbursts of
rage, but at first, Matula
cue-2206
remained calm. He rejoiced in the daily
gatherings for morning worship and the
cue-2207
singing of praise to God in the very place
where he had suffered so deeply.
cue-2208
But when he noticed many staying away from
prayers, he began visiting the nearby
cue-2209
hamlets to bring them in, and in doing so,
cue-2210
found himself beating some of them.
cue-2211
Realizing his danger, he begged his
friends to tie him up before he harmed
cue-2212
anyone. With heavy hearts, they tied him
loosely, but after he broke free, they had
cue-2213
no choice but to secure him more firmly,
his neck, hands, and feet bound.
cue-2214
Why did God allow this to happen to
Matula?
cue-2215
It is a great mystery,
cue-2216
one understood only by the light of
Christian suffering.
cue-2217
In his sane moments, Matula continued to
teach about God's love and the importance
cue-2218
of worship.
cue-2219
Once, he told his sister he had seen Jesus
coming for him with a host of angels.
cue-2220
His body, once so strong, could no longer
endure.
cue-2221
He grew too weak to stand, and the end
drew near. The cords were loosened, the
cue-2222
stick removed, and he was laid gently
down, surrounded by those who loved and
cue-2223
honored him deeply.
cue-2224
During his final days, he was only
occasionally conscious.
cue-2225
But in those moments, he would raise his
hand toward heaven and say,
cue-2226
Tala,
cue-2227
look.
cue-2228
His eyes would shine, and he seemed to
listen to something beyond the reach of
cue-2229
others.
cue-2230
Surely he saw the king in his glory,
calling him home.
cue-2231
On his last morning, a bright and
beautiful day broke over the earth,
cue-2232
and for Matula, it marked the beginning of
the eternal day of peace.
cue-2233
Though his end was a mystery, his life
remained a powerful testimony.
cue-2234
Even as these words were written, an
elderly woman, about sixty, told a
cue-2235
messenger that it was Matula who had
taught her to trust in the loving Savior.
cue-2236
She had once found joy in spiritual
things,
cue-2237
but after losing her only daughter, she
withdrew,
cue-2238
convinced God did not love her.
cue-2239
One day, Matula found her weeping and
shared with her the story of the widow of
cue-2240
Nayan in his own vivid way. He described
how the grieving mother had cared for her
cue-2241
only son, watching over him with deep love
until the day he
cue-2242
died.
cue-2243
In her sorrow, she cried out, beat her
head on the ground, and cut herself in
cue-2244
grief.
cue-2245
But then, a man full of majesty and
gentleness appeared. He told her not to
cue-2246
weep. Her son was only sleeping.
cue-2247
He touched the casket, and at once her son
lived again.
cue-2248
Overwhelmed with joy, she received her boy
back from the grave.
cue-2249
This story, so tenderly and powerfully
told by Matula, brought comfort
cue-2250
and faith to that grieving woman.
cue-2251
It was one of many ways he continued to
bless others, even in his final days.
cue-2252
-Then,
-said Matula,
cue-2253
I cannot say your child will return, but
Jesus remains as loving and
cue-2254
kind as ever. He has taken your child and
is keeping her safe for you.
cue-2255
Don't cry.
cue-2256
Trust him, and you will see your daughter
again.
cue-2257
Since then,
cue-2258
said the elderly convert,
cue-2259
my tears have ceased.
cue-2260
I've trusted the Savior and never doubted
his love.
cue-2261
Just a few weeks ago, Mr. Frame had the
joy of baptizing her in her own village.
cue-2262
As the sleep sickness began to turn into
madness, Matula spoke at a church meeting,
cue-2263
sensing his time was short.
cue-2264
He urged the believers to care for the
sick and suffering, especially those
cue-2265
afflicted with sleep sickness, who were
like those already under sentence of
cue-2266
death. He encouraged them to serve these
people with compassion, knowing that in
cue-2267
doing so, they were serving Christ, who
would reward them.
cue-2268
But if they showed no mercy, how could
they expect mercy themselves?
cue-2269
-Hell,
-he said,
cue-2270
is not a place made just for bad people,
but a place people prepare for
cue-2271
themselves by their actions.
cue-2272
With their evil deeds, they carry their
own firewood to fuel their torment.
cue-2273
This vivid image, likely heard from a
missionary, had taken root in his heart
cue-2274
and stayed with him.
cue-2275
You were a kind and Christ-like soul,
Matula.
cue-2276
On this earth, we shall not see you again,
cue-2277
but we will meet once more when the dawn
breaks and the shadows vanish.
cue-2278
Matula has entered heaven's eternal light.
cue-2279
Surely the angels have already rejoiced
over this precious soul, drawn out of the
cue-2280
darkness of Congo's soil.
cue-2281
For all the love, labor, sacrifice, and
tears poured into the work in
cue-2282
Congo, this one life redeemed by Christ's
blood is a worthy return.
cue-2283
And yet Matula was not alone. A noble one,
yes, but just one among many.
cue-2284
We thank God for the growing multitude
from Congo joining the ranks of the
cue-2285
redeemed, lifting their voices in the
great anthem. To him who loved us, to
cue-2286
him who conquered, to him who holds power
over death and darkness, glory
cue-2287
forever. Amen.
cue-2288
You have finished listening to A Miracle
of Modern Missions.
cue-2289
The story of Matula, a Congo convert.
cue-2290
Audiobook produced by scrollreader.com.
cue-2291
Listen to our audiobooks for free on our
site, YouTube, or Spotify.